so you can
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
yo what's up earth my name is thomas
dopaziola whatever you want to call me
this is the dope as usual podcast i am
here with marty o'neil what's up what up
this is dope usual podcast we're here to
talk about life drugs problems
accomplishments and everything in
between
today's gonna be all of that all right
all my notes say they hint on every
single thing here so guys fan requested
non-stop since we stopped i mean since
we started the show
you have requested this person
50 times a day what would you say at
least some yeah at least easy okay guys
i'm excited because i honestly don't
know a lot of these questions here we go
let's get started this is the raw og
brandon episode what's up
how are you doing how are you doing
first first interview
so give it a couple minutes you're gonna
ease into it and be like all right cool
we're just talking to you i know because
the first time it could be like
yeah especially with all the lights and
i'm like
these crispy new lights yeah no we got
some new lights going guys so what's up
dude thank you for coming to the show
thank you flying here thank you for
taking the time to come to another state
and hang out with us so
how do you like it how you how you been
these two hours we've been here
i've been good uh just had some
delicious berry tacos thanks to thomas
here he got me looked bomb i miss i do
miss cheese like that
i don't know how you doing
sometimes that looked it was a puddle of
cheese on this full stock
come on man
took about like what four or five bong
rips yeah i know you were going hard
yeah he was going hard about six seconds
before we started
um so real quick let's let's uh for
everyone out there i know a lot of
people are super stoked and a lot of
people like i'm not sure i've never i
don't watch weed youtube [ __ ] so for a
lot of people out there
in a nutshell what do you do for work
like if you could tell somebody what was
it the elevator pitch
like if you're in 30 seconds like what
do you do
the perfect way to put it is when i get
asked a lot is i'm in an uber or
something they're like oh like they're
trying to small talk what do you do and
i usually just say i do youtube videos
and that's what i usually leave it at
that i leave it at that um sometimes
they ask well what what type of youtube
videos and i usually just say vlog
that's a good one and then
people know what that means like i've
it's been very rare where someone's like
what's a vlog you know most people at
this time and age know what that is i
always think
we
entertainment videos man we just we just
hang out exactly it's hard to go i get
high as [ __ ] on the internet it's so
hard because you don't have to judge the
person like
are we gonna be okay after this are you
gonna [ __ ] be weird
i know you know that especially
um marty
are you ready i'm [ __ ] super ready
are you ready oh yeah okay so i'm gonna
get into these questions sorry guys i
am
extremely high too here we go i'm
nervous i am yeah
sorry um
we won't go get into it later but i've
been up since five smoking
weed were they actually there on time
today they were they were there on time
as they showed up we'll get into that
later just a little hint um let's start
off the uh this off i have a bunch of
questions to ask you
let's get off with the basics for
everyone i know where you're from but
for everyone out there where did you
grow up born and raised we talked about
this earlier before yeah born and raised
it sounds insane to me where did you
grow up las vegas yeah marty
do you imagine growing up in las vegas
it'd be tough
it'd be hard just based off of my
limited time in vegas when it was 120
[ __ ] degrees oh you're talking about
that yeah the earth
the the weather yeah yeah
in that sense i i was like what do you
mean tough but like i thought you meant
tough as in like you're not dead
yeah yeah that's kind of what i was
thinking i would have died at 14
overdoses
i don't go out i try not to go outside
during the summer it's 100
10 plus every day 105 on the low side
you go outside and you're in you know
that draining feeling
it's just as hot it's fasting it's been
yeah not just as hot but it's it's it's
almost up there yeah vegas is disgusting
so what i mean by how is it growing up
there as a child because
everyone here is las vegas even if
you're a kid you heard of las vegas sin
city people gamble
my parents did a great job me neither
kind of sheltering like i've been to the
strip in downtown and i remember being a
little kid and walking down like oh look
at these cards mommy and what you know
what they have the [ __ ] chicks on
them yeah yeah but the only time i would
be downtown is if i'm visiting a
relative or something that's coming in
town like in the strip or something when
i was a kid you know what i'm something
i
yeah
back then but um no they did a great job
i live about like 30 45 minutes away
from the strip uh 45 there's still towns
out that far i thought it was just vegas
yeah i live on the
centralized
there is central vegas there's north las
vegas there's henderson there's so many
different areas so like a lot of people
sometimes when they think of vegas you
grow up in a casino or in that area like
me i know i have to drive out to get on
the highway go all the way over there i
live far away from all that [ __ ] oh see
that's what my question was yeah
were you okay
for me
i would have died like i said earlier
i'd be dead there's too
much stuff to happen
and bad decisions that you know are bad
decisions
in vegas vegas is bad place i think for
me yeah
as a kid
okay were you a really good kid or
something
um
i i i'm trying to bri i'm trying to word
this like how were you not just face
first into cocaine
like
[ __ ] dove
olympic dove into a pile of strippers
that'd be me but you think of vegas i
can totally understand how a lot of
people could think of it like that but
actually the area that i grew up in was
pretty nice i grew up by a lot of
mormons actually and i was friends with
a lot of mormons growing up so when you
said are you a good kid or a bad kid it
kind of depends on who you ask
so
i was the outsider kid to all the the
mormon kids so like to a lot of the
parents i was a lot of parents like me
but some of them were like i don't
really like this kid i could get that
vibe and i still know it to this day and
i could sense i was an outsider
but a lot of the parents still to this
day i have so much respect for i'm still
friends with a lot of the kids to this
day i still keep in contact with a lot
of them on instagram and whatnot it's
not like i talk to them every day but um
uh
yeah they're good people that i grew up
with and
so if you ask
some of them they might think
i was a bad kid but if you ask the
average person no i didn't start smoking
weed or doing any of that type of stuff
until i was like a sophomore
oh okay so you're 14 ish going to 15.
i was 15 almost 16 the first time i
smoked oh really yeah oh you waited good
good for you some of my mormon friends
smoked weed before me for the first time
yeah so you're out and all right
over there is the bad [ __ ] you guys must
be talking about like we live in las
vegas you ever been to the strip oh i
saw some [ __ ] boobs the other day you
know like my dad i swear to god it
wasn't isolated like i knew what was
going on but i definitely it was a
more relaxed area there wasn't a whole
lot of crazy [ __ ] going on now there was
some kids who wanted to be gangster and
wanted to like try and live that life
like there is everywhere but
generally speaking no it's it's not a
bad area a mormon
i didn't expect that right i didn't
exactly there's a lot of mormons over
there not everyone is mormon i don't
want people to think that i just grew up
in like a mormon clique like
a lot of my friends were
for sure a lot of my close friends when
i was like a little kid because like i
was outside playing they were the
neighborhood kids they were who were you
know those are your friends because
they're there they were there
and they were really good friends
so i just find it crazy like how bad was
it as a kid i grew up in the nice part
of vegas i did not even know and or
expect that there was a part like that
so you weren't doing hard drugs as a kid
oh wow it was a [ __ ] this is one of
the few times okay here we go all right
so
if you aren't smoking weed what are you
doing as a kid in
not vegas what do you do what are you
doing
wait say that again like what if you're
not doing drugs prior to 15 what are you
doing out there what was i doing is it
merced i just
sit there i'm not in any gang
i go to the store get candy and come
back so me personally i wrestled i think
i told you before i grew up wrestling
um
i love to ski my dad's ski where okay so
there's actually a mountain at las vegas
it's really small it's all
yes it's all that we have i don't know
because what i'm going to get into it's
like really shitty when you compare it
to other really nice mountains across
the country
so when people come here like oh this
sucks but it's all that we have so it's
just like a small
top talk of [ __ ]
and it's cool though so what i was
getting at is my dad was a volunteer ski
patrol so he would get free like you
know season passes
so i got to
so you're that's what your dad did what
did your dad do and your parents you
said they kept you pretty sheltered and
did a good job they didn't really keep
me sheltered it's just i
i i just lived in a part of town where
there wasn't all that [ __ ] going on so
when i say they did a good job as far as
like the housing where they picked oh
okay and all that you know what i mean
like it's not like they
kept me inside and said no no they were
actually pretty um
like they let me do a lot of things that
a lot of parents probably wouldn't have
like at least compared to a lot of my
friends who had way more stricter
parents what they do for a living
so my dad's still to this day is a nurse
he's a transplant
yeah and then my mom works at the
springs preserve what's that
it's a
you can like go see animals and [ __ ]
sick wait out there it's in vegas
and okay
you grew up not around cocaine and you
ski in vegas what is happening there's
snow in the desert
you go into the mountains it's mount
charleston this the ski resort is called
lee canyon and it's actually been
gaining a lot of popularity throughout
the past few years at least it seems
because like i said i grew up going
there
and it got crowded sometimes when i was
a kid but now when i go there bro it is
[ __ ] like pastor is so
they they make a lot of the snow they
have oh there i knew it they have these
machines which a lot of resorts do but
then also we sometimes they get snow up
there but like that's not what they're
relying on we have good seasons we have
bad seasons
i still was gonna ask like you know what
remember i was telling you about my
first job there yeah artificial snow
yeah
yeah yeah he used to work at a place
like that but okay
so your parents did a pretty good job
you're into sports you're paying
attention
when do you first smoke weed and on that
topic what time is it i would say 11. oh
it's passed yeah okay you want these
joints
sure here here's one
it's the kush mountains
let's light this up maybe maybe we'll be
able to hit some bomb rips on this
because it might be demonetized city on
this episode so maybe we'll see let me
just say this real quick you want to
test it
i'm just saying i think bongs is like a
good way to
a good
indicator all right so for everyone out
there
i have lungs of a monster you see me
smoke crazy [ __ ]
this motherfucker's got lungs
all right that's why i bought that ball
cause this guy came over showed me what
i was missing out on in life and i went
and bought a bomb
shout out to luke shout out to luke and
brandon for putting me the [ __ ] on i'd
even know eric eight months before had
showed me my first sovereignty i didn't
even know that was
i saw a video later wait i have hit one
before you guys i didn't know that's how
much i don't pay attention yeah and then
when i really ripped yours that's when i
[ __ ] knew so
wrestling doing a good job your parents
doing a good job when did you first
smoke weed please give me the situation
pain paint us a picture would you have
long hair at the time no okay so i want
to make i'm trying to picture you like
all right cool a little brandon
short hair no [ __ ] coke or snow go
before i even get into that if you want
to get an idea of what i look like when
i was in middle school i used to wear
hollister
i was that kid i used to wear
abercrombie but just because i like the
striped shirt
yeah so i believe oh no american eagle
abercrombie there's a lot of people
i get it
but um so the first time i smoked weed
shout out to my good friend brando so he
was one of my friends that was already
smoking weed at the time and he was
mormon he was one of the like
there's a term they have jack mormon
that they call him like jack that's what
that's they have all these terms like if
you're a bad mormon they call you a jack
mormon so he was like yeah i'm a jack
warman he wasn't like that he was just
doing his thing but he was smoking weed
and
this is at the time where i was pretty
curious because if you this could be a
long story you go back to when i was in
fifth grade and i took the dare program
and i thought like weed was bad and [ __ ]
and then as i slowly grew up
you start
realizing like wait this [ __ ] isn't not
that bad you know so i did like research
because i actually
i wasn't the type of kid to just start
doing [ __ ] like i was like am i going to
put this into my body and i even thought
that at a young age so either way my
friend is smoking weed and i know that
he's doing fine and i pretty much just
asked him
and
the first time i believe
so the first time i smoked weed was
after my home or before my homecoming
night
at the football or after the football
game you know how that like the football
game before
i'm trying to remember it exactly so i
told him that i wanted to do it
and
he
got some weed from this one kid we went
and picked it up brought it to my house
he rolled a grape swisher
wow how's he first smoking that's great
and we smoked it on my rooftop at my
house and i didn't even get high okay
because i didn't know how to smoke i'm
like how do you do this i'm like
just like how do you do this
fast forward the first time i got high
made a [ __ ] waterfall bong i had some
weed in my house and it was just like
one day after school like a friday
had a little bit of weed left over from
i think maybe that night or something
how much longer were you making your own
pieces from the first night you smoked a
joint to the grit to the waterfall bomb
like how long did it take you to be like
i smoke weed by myself now
how long
a week or two oh damn this fool's on
it's quick
all right all right it's quick so you're
sitting there you first time you really
get high the waterfall bung keep going
um so i do the waterfall bong and
i've told this story actually on my
channel and my memory is like probably
way better in that video because i told
it a while ago because it was either way
i took two hits that was it and you know
if you've never really gotten high
before you don't have a tolerance it
does not take a lot and i just got
[ __ ] ripped out of my mind like i was
so stoned and it almost for like maybe a
moment scared me away but i knew like
i just kind of overdid it like i had no
tolerance like i kind of had that yeah
you knew what was wrong like i [ __ ]
hit the gravity button twice
because i took the first hit
and i never knew what being high was
like so like
by the time i took my sec do you know
what i'm saying by the time i took my
second hit at shotgun man i didn't know
what to do it crept up on me
and i was 15 16 yes and it took you
about a week to start smoking weed on
your own
so you get high for the first time and
realize you overdid it
now what happens are you the kid at
school that's getting [ __ ] up because
you said
you started your youtube at 16 right oh
you have an ashtray right here too yeah
i just spoke ash
yeah i just saw it it was an accident
can i just put it right here yeah yeah
so
you started your youtube at 16 years old
weed videos
so let me think was i 16.
it was may 2005 i believe i was 16 yeah
yes i was 16.
you're uploading weed videos
yes the balls
on
dude it first because it wasn't like i
yeah i this
just started uploading videos like hey
i'm smoking weed i have a lot of them
that are still privatized where i was
putting things like editing things over
my faces was cutting it below where you
could just it was just like a 30 second
video of me taking a bong rip or
something like that and i slowly started
like showing showing and talking and
then like
i just fell in love with it and you're
in school
yes i was i was a junior in high school
so when is the first time someone comes
up and goes hey
i've seen you on youtube [ __ ]
getting high
the first time was my senior year in
high school and by this time i already
hit a hundred thousand
so did people know that you're doing
this only a few people so whoa oh 100
and you're at school
that's [ __ ] crazy and you're showing
your face yeah
so
there's so much to it like when i really
think about it right here
go for it so brando my good friend that
i was mentioning that started smoking
weed before i really even hit big
numbers people were already finding me
but they weren't no one would come up to
me and say anything
i wasn't that much of a uh
i didn't put myself out there too much
like so i just kind of like kept to
myself especially maybe you couldn't say
that my freshman year i feel like as i
start smoking weed that's when i really
just like kind of like exactly yeah so
people were coming up to brando and they
were like yo i'm seeing brandon on
youtube and he's smoking weed and he
kept telling me yo people are seeing you
so the first time someone actually came
up to me
because prior to this no one would come
up to me i would be in and out of school
i
tried to ditch school a lot we can get
into that
um
but
my senior year i was in the counselor's
office waiting to speak to my counselor
and some kid sits down and then he like
looks up at me and he gave me this look
and i instantly knew like oh [ __ ] and i
just like
he's like are you raw g and i was just
like yeah and i kind of like
i don't remember if i told him not to
say anything but
i don't know if i gave him the look or
something but he didn't like
you didn't snitch me out but the main
thing i was really worried about was um
someone like a teacher or someone like
finding my shin like trying to get me in
trouble
because thousands yeah you're showing
your face and go to school
that's paranoid city i would be looking
on my shoulders every five seconds
homeschooled
well could you imagine the anxiety of
that marty no hold on if you got caught
knowing would your parents be pissed
ah yeah
okay so there is that anxiety there is
that like yeah and i would feel really
bad because i wouldn't want to get them
in trouble yeah either like you're like
because they
they didn't
they'd be like what it would be news to
them as well
oh i get it so first of all my parents
are divorced so
i was doing all this
at my dad's house not because he allowed
it but he was at work he was at work my
mom was at work but i also knew deep
down like you know your parents well if
i got caught by my mom
i would like how you say your mom would
have been over oh so you have that fear
too my mom's not from this country
where's from she's from iran okay she'll
just beat the [ __ ] out of you she won't
beat the [ __ ] out of me but like
if i get it you're like no i'm not going
to be good it would not have so like if
my dad catching me it would have been he
would have it would have been okay but
it would have been a lot
i wouldn't have got my ass kicked pretty
much he's from here he's from kansas
does he smoke weed
yeah i mean
not like
not nearly as much as me like when you
when i say yes he's weed friendly he's
not gonna be like get away from me
exactly yeah guys like he's not like a
stoner by any means it's like if
anything it's like one little like pie
pin good for like however like
i get it
that's cool though as long as like he's
not looking at you like you junkie does
your mom know you do this yeah now is
she okay with it yeah okay cool how
about your dad yeah 100 all right cool
cool yeah at the time
they didn't know um it was definitely a
fear for me of like
someone getting caught yeah so you're in
the office you're getting caught yeah
just going shut the [ __ ] up kids yes
so what happens
it's the first time
i went and i yeah that was it that's the
only time because if we go into how i
was in high school by the time i started
smoking weed
i was trying to pass all my classes
without ac without do with doing the
least amount of anything so i would
if i was in a class where i knew i could
get marked on the like when they're
doing the um attendance and then leave
it up and then leave right now
all the time all the time
so
waiting for them to turn around bam
i hated doing it but i always felt bad i
always felt bad like i just [ __ ] in your
face i just said [ __ ] you and your whole
time and walked i hated it so i'd have
to sneak
i couldn't do it to their face i felt so
so rude
me too yeah i couldn't because i was
never really like
i just didn't like it's not like school
i'm not rude exactly
perfect i didn't know what to say like i
didn't wasn't an [ __ ] i wasn't a dick
i just didn't want to be there like
i could tell stories about when i was
ditching and [ __ ]
hall monitors coming off after me and
their little orange go carts and [ __ ] i
don't know chase you down yeah i had to
change them i had to like run and yeah
[ __ ] did they ever catch you no
that was a crazy he looks fast yeah you
do look fast you do look at your fast
did you play football
i did for one year in fourth grade and
then after that fifth grade wrestled
until the whole time yeah once i found
wrestling that i knew that was my sport
really and yeah good [ __ ] because like
football dude to be honest i loved
playing it with all my friends like i
said in the park with all my mormon
friends you know it was fun at the park
but then when we put on the pads and you
get all these bigger kids like i'm small
dude i was getting cracked out there and
like i honestly like just wasn't having
that good of a time
football in fact wrestling you have your
own weight classes you're going against
kids who are your weight you know are
you good at wrestling
um like i would say
there's levels to this [ __ ] so if i say
i'm good someone's going to say you're
you're not as good as me but that's fine
that means you could maul the average
human yeah the average guy is not going
to be able to take you down in your
weight class you know hold on the
average guy might wait 100 yeah but like
if you put me up against someone who's
like an athlete and does this yeah it's
gonna be a good match
like uh did you ever make it to state
yeah i went to oh get the [ __ ] out it's
all you had to say like i went to state
finals i went to state for three years
and the best i did was take third and
then
my second year in state so my coach was
the head of the snwa um wrestling
association or
southern nevada wrestling so he was the
president of that
and he was able to make me a ref and
like get paid so i was going to like
state and i'd like a uniform and like
all the other kids on the wrestling team
who were in high school no i was still
in middle school
at the time yeah what but i was but this
was for um it wasn't for high school i
wasn't reffing high schoolers or
anything it wasn't like a little middle
school getting paid it was like fifty
dollars or a hundred a day that's
awesome a lot of money as a kid
it was
it's a whole video game
yeah so like while i wasn't wrestling
i'd be reffing other matches and then
they'd call your name on the stadium on
the phone
and then you'd go wrestle
so like they they didn't just let anyone
ref they had to like
at least at least go you have to go
through classes yeah coach recommends
you and you have to also go through
certain classes so you're good at
wrestling
i don't want to brag but i'm all right
you have to say it right there you went
to state i got stuck on a local level i
did great by my second third year
wrestling i was taking first at a lot of
tournaments
then when you start traveling you start
competing against kids who are in other
states and like there's higher there's
bad asses
that's where kids would put my ass to be
real like i you know what i'm saying so
i've gotten my ass [ __ ]
i've gotten killed in wrestling man i
mean
embarrassment
philip souza i know you're watching this
[ __ ] what's up phillip dude i once got
you know the chicken hold when you're on
your chest someone's got both arms
behind like the oh the chicken wing yeah
i got chicken
dude i got chicken winged on my [ __ ]
chest my leg sprawled so he couldn't
move my body weight
first time my grandma ever showed to my
my [ __ ] match my face is down and
she's right here at the stands and i'm
just all i can do is stare at my ground
[ __ ] man it's the only time you've been
in the game
i'm not done the worst feeling two
rounds
we got up
went to the next period all that [ __ ]
and he did it again to me right back to
the bat right back to the [ __ ] mat
man handled me and he was my religion
during the same move the same [ __ ]
move cause what i was trying to do is
get away get away he's trying to push me
and just the way it folds he just ah
and i'm for two whole [ __ ] oh my god so
yeah i've been embarrassed yeah i've
been [ __ ] stuck i've been dropped on
my neck i've been firemen environment
carried once and i was so embarrassed
you're flailing your legs around it's
like you don't think it's robin thrown
for five firemen
i think it was at stake
oh this shit's embarrassing getting ma
thing is i was a fat kid so i'm
wrestling i'm a sixth grader writing all
the eighth graders every [ __ ] match
dude fool's got stubbles and i'm over
here like [ __ ] i mean you're behind in
my grade
i'm 11. you guys are about to be in high
school this is [ __ ] because i was
always i was 135's in sixth grade dude i
was a big [ __ ] giant fat kid not
really but you know it sucked man have
you thought about getting into jiu jitsu
now yes i have 100 i'm now that you're
watching ufc too huh i've been getting
into ufc and it's
it's i mean a wrestler's background's
the best fighting that's what it always
is you're just talking about that yep
yeah i mean what what's your thoughts on
that being a wrestler do you feel like
in mma wrestlers have the advantage over
all the other arts
it's really tough to say because it
comes down to skill
um yeah for sure but
i feel like when wrestlers go in they
have a really good chance of holding
their own especially against someone who
might be really good at striking but
doesn't have the best wrestling defense
like conor mcgregor oh yeah like i'm not
going to try and act like i'm an expert
on any means but
like when you when you put them against
someone like khabib you saw what
happened like
he couldn't do anything there's nothing
you can't punch if you can't get off
your back basically 100 dude i'm really
good at wrestling i just
i i don't know it's almost like a game
where can i take you down before you
knock me out if that's the case and when
i go down don't uppercut me come on
don't overcome you're not just getting
your ass
because they can throw knees i don't
want to be down well that's like a rule
i guess i don't want to fight
people in a ring knowing that there's
cambodian kickboxers alive on earth have
you seen these people they kick down
trees and they kick trees down
that's the training they kick trees down
with their shins have any of them been
in the ufc before i don't know but i
don't want to [ __ ] find out i don't
ever want to find one of these dudes
they're the dudes that spocks with one
leg up
and then they kick you in the [ __ ]
teeth and kill you yeah yeah i don't
want anything to do with that i don't
there's eight-year-old little girls out
there doing that [ __ ] growing up break
my whole head tell you what though the
dagestani russians in the ufc are where
it's at they are bringing the game to a
whole another i don't know who they are
but even them i don't want to fight them
either yeah anybody that's like yo break
my teeth oh
oh i don't want to get in the face get
away from me that's interesting like
what do you think
i haven't really wrapped my mind around
that culture but it's interesting
because it's like a must correct me if
i'm wrong like a muslim-based russian
culture i i believe so i don't want to
speak on what i don't know i will but
i have no idea i watched the documentary
we were talking about it
documentary they were very i only
watched the first episode yeah he's
russian they dude yeah oh so he's muslim
russian
i don't know
yes because uh nikita my videographer is
russian he tells me like dude we have
all ethnicities russian like home like
there's no white russia like you're
russian
so there's asian dudes i speak fluent
russians in my town
but they're from china because china's
right down the [ __ ] street and they
grew up here he's like oh i know a lot
of [ __ ] people from jerusalem that
grew up here they're they're russian
russia is [ __ ] awesome from what he
explains it to me but i don't know that
group but i do know they fight bears
they live in the mountains if i bears
bro khabib used to wrestle bears that's
like a i'm cool
i think there's videos of him wrestling
a bear when he was a little kid watch
wwf and see there's no comparison to
that
you know what i mean when there's
fighters like that out there we can
never really do much yeah no you can
never feel tough it's the mentality of
like this guy used to [ __ ] eat ice
[ __ ] this i'm not fighting him he's on
another level not only that his just
the way they live as far as i've seen
their discipline how hungry they are
like they don't play around
yeah it's a scary dude when i've been
looking at all these uh
they've been fighting obviously for
years but i just found out about a lot
of them recently islam makachev
umar newmar nurmagomedov they're a lot
dude their names are so hard to
pronounce
um
i know i've been driving
there's so much
he's one of the youngest ufc fighters
right now so bad he's like 21. i've been
following it so that's i that's how i
know but
i just watched him fight and
yeah he beat the [ __ ] out of cody durden
[Laughter]
do you see 4c in your opinion any stars
coming up in the ufc it's a weird
in my from my perspective it's really
weird time in ufc because they've kind
of cycled through the superstars to the
point that there's no no no there's some
i've been watching fight nights and i've
this has only been a few times and i see
some dudes who are coming up that most
uh like average casual mma like watchers
or people watch ufc maybe not have heard
of or seen him know there are some dudes
out there that are [ __ ] gonna come up
and
it's it's it's evolving dude yeah fools
are just scary
no the the
ufc is on another level then it's i mean
there's always been insane fighters
throughout there's no doubt but it's
pretty much no it's yeah like there's
more badasses
all the time
people aren't gonna go i think i can do
that and then they train they used to be
[ __ ] they're just like in their
family their fighters and they train now
they're usc fighters not all the time
but i'm saying it was
now for social media and this and oh i'm
gonna go get sponsored as a [ __ ] and
you really get into fighting now you're
in the ufc like what the [ __ ]
there's fools that come up on five
really cool wins and now they're on tv
yeah you know
so it's social media really helps that
you know
but uh for sure yeah i don't really get
into anyway sugar shawn let's make this
[ __ ] happen i know we've been uh
we've been waiting we're waiting on you
man come on that that was the one fight
that like
i've of course known of ufc
i grew up wrestling and i've liked it
it's been one of my favorite sports
but that fight when he beat the [ __ ] out
of chris moutinho
that was the one that like got me hooked
and like ever since then i started
really like watching and keeping up with
the ufc more that's when the dude i was
like why won't you die
that was [ __ ] scary the zombie dude
yeah it kind of made me feel like is he
is he okay yeah like something did he go
out but he's just still there
sean
he was fighting in a dream yeah
you hit a [ __ ] 40 times he goes
hey get hurt it's so strange because he
just went three rounds with sean
o'malley but then he just fought like a
week ago and then got tko'd in the first
round by a dude in his 40s
um i don't get strength
old man strength is a real thing
yeah that's true dudes with grease on
their pants that's true
um
okay
real quick let me get back onto another
topic i wanted to bring up
marty i'm really excited to bring this
up because you'll relate to this a lot
i talked to you about this earlier and
said hey i really want to bring this up
on the show
i want to say i know i asked you like
this earlier but i'ma say it like this
and you just lead it
how on earth do you not talk about your
music
more often
can you tell everybody
that you have
another persona you do music as and say
and because some people are gonna go i
have that [ __ ] on my spotify
yeah i don't know how deep this goes
because in my mind it'd be crazy to have
some big ass youtube channel and not use
it to promote your music
i did in the beginning but i was going
to say i haven't made music in a while
um
the past month or two i have had a few
couple tracks that i've been like kind
of working on you know a lot of it is
lyrics that i've written from
months ago and it's beats that i've been
sitting on because like i said i haven't
done it in a while
but um tell everybody tell everybody the
name you i want you to like how did you
start that why did you pick that name
because i okay there's some people that
might go on here and go wait this is the
same [ __ ] dude yeah because when you
play to go you make music and play to go
[ __ ] i think i called him like oh yo
are you [ __ ] kidding me and i played
him like are you serious this shit's
hard so can you thank you tell us so how
did you come up with that would you win
so when i first came up with the name
evil main so that's the name if you
don't know
um i can't remember the exact like year
it was probably
2014-15 oh you were young as [ __ ] yes i
was young
and i came up with that name before i
even started making music it wasn't like
all right my name's evil maine and i'm
gonna start rapping how it happened was
i had a i made a soundcloud account and
i was really just
into that the whole underground genre
and i just made my name evil man like
there was no other rapper named that and
i didn't even really think about making
music at the time he's had it yeah and
then it's a whole nother sort of like
how i like got into soundcloud and all
that but yeah so tell me what was it
so how i got into soundcloud so
this goes back into
2013 and fourteen this is years ago so
shout out to my brother bryce
so
i still have that joint there okay yeah
no no
um
so
at this point in time i think i was a
freshman and
my brother and his friend
were really into this music um
and what would happen is they would come
and pick me up from school or landon
his my brother's friend his name is
landon sorry he would come and pick me
and my brother up to take us to school
and i'd be sitting in the back scene
he'd be playing some music and at this
time i had no clue what it was and it
would always be really hard it was bones
at the time okay i don't know if you
know exactly and i had no idea so this
is like 2013-14
he's picking me and my brother up i'm in
the backseat like oh this shit's hard
and eventually i didn't even like say
anything i just kind of like saw it on
the screen looked it up started
listening to it at home
um he would also listen to denzel curry
that's how it got me into it even prior
to this my brother was into like other
underground memphis uh evil pimp gangsta
pat um
36 mafia they're not really that
underground but he was listening to that
[ __ ] so
yeah
so that's how you said okay i like this
kind of music exactly
so when it's just a very young age
yeah that's fall you were young as [ __ ]
you had to be what 14
so i was a freshman yeah yeah damn
okay so when did you start actually
making the music and then putting it
online
and then we'll get to what else we
talked about in the car then we'll get
into that
so um
excuse me
it was right after my senior year i
believe so i think i was
18 19 when i first made my first song
but um
yeah i was listening to
i was really into soundcloud um you can
go back i'm sure a lot of you guys know
who like suicide boys is ghostmen so
like i watched all those guys come up
and i thought it was so cool at a young
age you know i watched them too when i
found that genre of music of all these
different artists i've like full went
into i was like this is so cool
listening to it liking all their songs
and um
yeah it just went on of like finding new
artists this hat i'm wearing the
devilish trio these were the dudes who
solidified my inspiration to start
making music because i like really like
this that type of uh just hard
underground you know like i love that
like that memphis [ __ ] you know but
these guys brought like their own twist
to it where they were just speaking some
real [ __ ] into their lyrics but also
being hard as [ __ ] and i resonated with
that and like i just
thought to myself like i can do this too
like there's
some rappers out here who are good and
there's some in the underground who suck
so like i'm gonna come in here and
[ __ ] show them who can also do it
let's go yeah
[ __ ] yeah
i was i uh
i popped up my light
liked songs when i was actually this
morning i was like all right we're gonna
go pick him up after this today and it
popped i'm like dude i'm i gotta bring
this up on the [ __ ] podcast so
um
you are putting your music on soundcloud
you get a lot of comments and people
like yo i wish it was on spotify
take it away go ahead
so
as i was saying i originally started
posting my music on soundcloud
and
spotify's been around for a while but
it's more of a
like more people use spotify than they
use soundcloud
so i was like i need to put my music on
spotify other platforms so i found out
how to distribute my music and this was
years ago so i started i went and i
distributed all my old tracks that i had
already done and then since then
whenever i post a new track i would
automatically just distribute it i don't
remember exactly when i started doing it
but
i started getting my music on spotify
and um so what he's getting at in the
car is
you know at the end of the year where
it's like january december 31st and
everyone's posting like their spotify
like oh this is the most played artist
or whatnot
and then also there's artists the artist
version where they have all the like
statistics so i went and i was just like
looking at my statistics and i was like
wow these like numbers are like really
great at actually [ __ ] millions yeah
it shits on my uh soundcloud numbers
because just more people are on
soundcloud
and then it just i was just like
wondering i was like am i getting paid
for these um because i never like really
thought about it like i was getting like
barely anything from soundcloud and i
was just i was doing it all for the fun
and the love like like you're like i
wonder if they got me paid yeah i just
started wondering that and uh i went on
to my distributor website and i just
like tuned core
what's that tunecore
uh no
oh there's another one i thought that
was the only one there there's a lot
there's distrokid there's there's many
so i go on there and i go into my bank
and it like makes you put in all your
like financial information
before you can actually see the number
and like for the past i think like two
and a half years there's just all this
money that was just like accumulated
that i had no clue about
and i was just like what the [ __ ] like
best feeling i had no idea
i was making money from yeah
we won't say it but whoa yeah just from
music you're already made for fun
yeah
because a lot of people like because
soundcloud has a uh
it's almost like a negative like a
soundcloud rapper like you're obsessed
with clout
i didn't i really just loved the music
and wanted to like
do it myself you know it's like i want
to do this
and it's crazy because
i know it's really corny for people to
say like do your passion it'll turn into
money do it but it's like really [ __ ]
true
everything when i look back at
everything i've done in my life that
i've done out of passion and just
wanting to do out of the fun i've
somehow ended up making money out of it
whether it's
youtube music
you know
like there's just keep going yeah video
games twitch i haven't twitched streamed
in a while and i want to get back into
it but it's like there's so many ways
you can find a way
to to to make to make it work
see you hear this [ __ ] oh yeah we were
just talking about this yeah we're
talking about this last episode like
don't matter what you can
go get a job while you do this [ __ ] that
you really love and maybe one day this
year i was so lucky because i found out
at a young age because a lot of people
don't find that out and i'm not trying
to brag like i am like
i'm thankful because
at a young age i was before i even
graduated i had this following and i
knew like
when you go back to the counselor
conversation when the kid recognized me
i was going in there to tell my
counselor i didn't want to go to college
like oh [ __ ] that's what i was going in
there to get the talk and then they
really like pressure it on you like are
you sure what are you gonna do
and they like really and obviously i'm
not saying hey i'm doing this
if you really want to
i wanted to say this on the podcast
because it's funny to just give people a
perspective
um so when i went to hempfest it was
like the first hempfest i went out to
seattle seattle hem fest
that was
i when i came back from that trip on
that sunday the next monday i had my
first day of school in my senior year so
i was literally in hemp fest meeting
fans
and then seeing your
dude it was
and that goes into the whole thing i
said ditching is
i
was not having it like i was getting in
fights with my dad's like not bad like
he was just like brandon you need to go
to because it's a big like
generation difference like he wants me
to go to college he wants me to go to
school
and
um
i get it
for you to be able to handle that [ __ ]
made you mature quick as [ __ ]
because i remember being in college my
second year in college and i had a big
following already and i remember there'd
be times
like yo
i gotta get the [ __ ] out of here i see
these fools looking at me i don't it's
weird i don't want people coming up to
me they think i'm gonna [ __ ] rob me
what's going on it's before i got used
to like
nobody ever came up to me i could see
people look you know like and here's the
good part what's what
i mean like what are you looking at
by the time i made big numbers like a
hundred thousand i was in my senior year
if you have most of your credits by the
time you're senior at least in vegas you
only have like half days that's if you
have a lot of credit i had a lot of my
credits
so i only had half days
and
out of those half days i only needed to
complete so i had four classes and they
had like even an odd schedule so like
one day i'd have two classes the next
day another two classes but there's four
total if that makes sense
and you'd switch off each day so each
day i would only have one required class
that required a credit so i would ditch
the other one so i'd only go to one
class every day
so i'd barely be at school so like i
wouldn't really give people the chance
to got you
got you you're lucky and when i was and
also when i was a junior i still had a
following but this was when i said
people were going to my friend brando
and they were going up to him so i
didn't really
believe it or not as being at a young
age i didn't get that many people like
running up to me in school because oh
for sure
school i was also anxious and [ __ ] like
a lot of people are watching this one to
my school a lot of people thought i was
like a school shooter kid when i was
this is a lot of trench coats and boots
this was later on if my friends who knew
me obviously didn't think that but like
if you didn't know me
i don't know i just i think i had bad
social anxiety in high school when i
look back every morning
i didn't really have that many friends
to stand out with so i would go in the
stalls and just stand there by myself
until the bell rang totally fill you i
did the organ i just wait because
everyone's all with their friends and
like i look back and i'm like wow but
it's what i did and i did that in oregon
for like almost a year
like i don't want to stand around and
go yeah so i would go in a small go
somewhere else just stand there and i
know how many people just went [ __ ] me
and at this point in time i was so many
people just thought that i was getting
high as [ __ ] every morning before school
i wasn't
smoking joints i would take a bong or if
i'd be concise that is that a word
concise i'd be precise with my [ __ ] i
would take a bonket make sure no smoke
gets on me because i didn't want the kid
coming up to me at school and being hey
you smelly green and then
like i didn't like that that happened to
me a few times just because i maybe
didn't
do a good enough job yeah i get it
exactly but for the most part no i would
go to school and actually i'm not
telling if you're young and you're
watching this i'm not trying to
encourage i'm just speaking from my
experience but
i would smoke every morning get stupid i
go to my algebra 2 class and i'd knock
that [ __ ] out and it was because i had
to like i
really had to pass that class i didn't
want to let my parents down like
i know what you mean and
i made all my way up through
school
and math specifically math was not my
subject i never paid attention i just
cheated and then this all the way up
until algebra two i finally had to pay
attention i'd go to that class high
every morning but i
i take that energy you know when you're
really high and you get focused in what
you're doing
you know what i mean oh god do not do
that and i would just
go and i pay attention and i passed that
class with the b which was really good
for me like a b algebra two amazing i
didn't know a thing about algebra one so
that was
like
so
and my teacher was great like
shout out i'm not going to say her name
i don't know about part one
algebra 2 is the only class i have to
pass to finish college that was math was
the only thing that i could i hate it i
could pretty much not try and do well in
almost every other class the only chance
the reason my grade would go down is
because i wouldn't do the homework
you're like me
yeah if i'm there i'll do some [ __ ]
i'm not going to do the homework
come on you got me the whole [ __ ]
thing i haven't done homework and it's
been instilled in me since i was a kid
and i look back at things that
so when i was in kindergarten i can i'm
sorry if i'm ranting go for it that's
why we have these joints and life
so when i was in kindergarten
they like my teacher would give us like
these little whatever [ __ ] little
kid assignments and we had these like
little cubbies where he'd go and he'd
put our work in
and then at the end of the day you were
as a kid like i remember you'd go and
you take and then you'd bring it home
i would just let it stack up in my thing
i never took it home my mom would ask me
oh where's your homework and i would
just lie to her i'd be like
if i don't think my mom's ever gonna
watch this but if she even if she did if
she did show him she'll remember this
and
show
where i was lying and i was like i don't
have any homework and then finally the
teacher talked to my mom and i got in
big trouble like oh so you did have
homework and you were lying to me
so when i look back that's what i'm
getting at i was doing that when i was
like five i've never liked being told
what to do or people like i've never
liked that [ __ ] and i'm not saying
it's just it's just your personality
exactly if you know you had to do it
your mom forced you you would have done
it but you you try to play it off as
long as once i got pun ex it was the
first time i was in kindergarten in
preschool you didn't have homework i
went to preschool so this is my first
time my first time ever getting the
teacher giving me a homework assignment
i tried to when i was five
my uncle uh used to bury his homework
and throw it in the outside water pump
house in my grandma's my uncle's uh
younger than me because my grandma had
him way late okay
and then one time we found it like a
boneyard
and there was months of homework stacks
that's so over the top stacked and we
just talked to me uncle just talked
about a couple days ago he's like four
years younger than me but i talked about
it when you got caught like burying your
homework goes bro i'm like there's
nowhere to dump it because if you're in
school you walk out there's everybody
you get on the bus you're in the country
there's nowhere to throw it away uh bury
it that's what i would have done too so
now that i think about it like
all right i would've i used to hide my
homework i used to pretend
teacher said there's no homework today
mom
[ __ ] [ __ ] nobody can relate to that
one you know what i mean like i feel you
you're like me marty did you do homework
that would have never [ __ ] dawned on
me yeah i just skated by did you do the
homework yeah i mean kind of like as
much as i had to to [ __ ] not fail
yeah yeah that's the same if i had you
guys are talking about math how about
this [ __ ] i failed maths senior year and
junior year all right but junior year i
had to go to summer school i had to ride
my bike through a cemetery through the
rain to summer school every day all
summer
they had put me in a completely
different [ __ ] math class
than the one i had actually failed and i
didn't even [ __ ] notice was it easier
or harder i don't [ __ ] know
how does that even happen
how do you not know like oh this is a
different class than i did all year
because you were paying attention
that's your fault my teacher would walk
by in my notes would i just be drawing
and oh yeah sons in the corner
army trucks oh that's me all day
yeah
i didn't like school either
the [ __ ] you i just sit in the stall
stand there to the railway ah i feel
that [ __ ] so hard
when i went to oregon it was the worst
god i hate that [ __ ] feeling it's the
worst
dude that's me at nightclubs
i'm leaving why am i here i [ __ ] hate
nightclubs
with a passion i hate nightclubs like i
hate racism
that's how much i hate them they're
boring
it's just loud music hey who's that
i'm trying um
having the best time of her [ __ ] life
i'm standing here like a [ __ ] mean
mug and [ __ ] you don't have to do
anything if your girl just like ah
can i can i get them that's all it is
for girls for dudes like this guy's
staring at me these guys are no choice
yeah
man i just want to smoke weed why am i
here
i'm going i'm going home hey you're good
i'm going i'm so thankful i've had that
in me
i've never been to a strip club i've
never been to like an actual bar
like i've been to like i've been
downtown with my friends you live in
vegas yeah and you
i don't do any of no wow
not for me see the thing is rosie likes
strip clubs too so
paying i mean as a guy it's like you're
just paying for blue balls
yeah i get that but strip clubs are so
fun
it's like yo
all right here you go [ __ ] all right
all right i'm gonna leave
i went to a strip club
two three times they're like yeah
25 for that bottle of water i'm like oh
[ __ ] whatever it was i'm like [ __ ] i
need my change actually what changed the
economics of the strip club for marty no
like by myself with like some friends i
don't want to go to strip club
for what well hey i
i have that's not
yeah it's never been me no thanks yeah
i'm good on everything basically yeah
maybe if i was single would be cooler
uh-huh but with
yeah pointless no i don't need [ __ ] what
do you do you just like get food and
rosie yeah
i don't ever eat just if you can eat the
strip club you shouldn't go okay
i don't know anything about this one
okay so in l.a there's this i won't say
where but there's a strip club that they
serve food and when they serve food at
ship clubs it's a no-go for me
i walked in no exaggeration all right
here you go you're gta you're walking
into a strip club because you've never
been imagined right
i walk in
real story 100 no exaggeration i walk
into the strip club
and there's like a
six foot lady like she's a pretty tall
lady but she's a big lady
she's a stripper she has like a fishnet
gown on with like underwear
cooking going in on a burrito
guys when i say
she's eating a burrito not like a taco
bubbler you're like oh
dainty this [ __ ] had double fisted a
[ __ ] burrito and it was already like
right here at an angle like she had been
going to town on it and i went rosie
oh my [ __ ] god why are we here
oh my god why are we here it's like this
trip you ever seen that that's my boy
the movie that's my boy with adam's
family that's the strip club he went to
essentially if you haven't there's a
really gross one i'm not done
not done you can ask rosie that is weird
for some reason it's the nasties like
the others [ __ ]
you work here what the [ __ ]
but the worst part was there's like four
dudes standing this girl's
dancing ask rosie marty
this [ __ ]
is
half ass shaking her ass
no effort
she's just doing a dog when the dog's
like all right phil give me the [ __ ]
all right you're gonna [ __ ] give me
the food when they were [ __ ] stoked
and they're like not stoked anymore
that's the [ __ ] effort she's given
i swear to god me and rosie looked at
each other like we gotta get the [ __ ]
out of here this [ __ ] has a plate of
wings and she's eating the wings and
there's dudes throwing money at her
behind her as she's eating wings
no effort shaking she's killing it
she's just doing what she would be doing
at home exactly exactly it's like she
was about to start stretching
and she's just eating [ __ ] dude
place in l.a i won't i'll tell you after
it's a popular place i think i think
it's pretty popular
is it known for weird [ __ ] or that just
no it's just they just serve that's just
what goes they deserve food i guess
there's no break room there's something
oh no
that's not like a comedy club it was a
stripper
eating wings there were saucepans like
she has to have a napkin to clean her
hands after
yeah
what kind of decision oh what kind of
wings i'll be on stage
chipotle barbecue sauce like [ __ ] a
stripper would want a nice light salad
before going on or something
my stomach sucks
i would [ __ ] my pants big ass [ __ ]
burrito shit's going on backstage and
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] sorry so that's not
all strip clubs yeah let's just say that
that's just a street what i went to when
they serve food there you go when they
serve food just go somewhere so you
normally just need rosie go to strip
clubs and and we
spend too much money rosie throws money
at girls in clumps and you're supposed
to spread it out and then she throws it
in clumps softballs softball clumps
underhands
now i can imagine underhand softball she
was a pitcher yeah that's funny i [ __ ]
with that you know you're not missing
anything fun okay it's cool i didn't
think i was i went as a single dude once
i'm like oh this is cool
i did that peace i peaced out i left but
going with rosie's cool because it's
like
something crazy happens i'm not like
it's it's on you
you're not me
i'm just a bystander
and um
strip clothes are okay but if you're in
vegas that's crazy you've never been to
one that's
easy and then growing up in vegas um
sorry that was a long ramp no no that's
completely fine what i was going to say
is
correlating to strippers lots of girls
that you may have went to high school
with or else
not not all of them but like a few a
handful nine out of ten and i can't say
i'm not gonna like generalize but like
nine out of ten about all the girls that
i knew that ended up being strippers or
someone that i really wouldn't want to
like hang around so like when i kind of
like see it's like okay is that type of
environment oh i got you because you're
in the core of it
i wouldn't say well i'm saying you're in
vegas i've seen it's a few you know and
i can't generalize because somebody's
yeah like oh that girl in high school
wasn't that nice and she's a stripper
are all strippers like that yeah so i
see what you're saying yeah i'm not
gonna go into a mean person place or a
[ __ ] weirdo but i guess just like
i'm getting my like there i feel like
they're just trying to get your money
and i'm like get away from me
i know yeah i totally get away totally
like uh
it's just like you might see that's all
is that like strippers hook into vegas i
have no [ __ ] idea yeah all right
cause that because it's like legal there
right like i don't know about that it's
not legal right or brothels are legal in
vegas no you have to like go to paramp
for that i found i don't even know that
i find that because i originally thought
that you could i thought it was legal
here and then someone i forget who it
was someone told me and i looked it up
and i was like oh [ __ ] they have like
brothels and [ __ ] yeah because i heard
that they have that it's like 30 45
minutes i believe it's another parum is
like another show it's like a legal
place or something i don't know it's
like uh uh hugh hefner who's just
watching the huge hefner show and they
talk about it it's like a bunny ranch or
something so at a broadcast you just
like i don't know i thought that was all
vegas was because i know it's a sexy
[ __ ] two when i was a kid
when i was a kid i thought the same
thing like i've always been curious how
it all works
i don't know how that works
that'd be a fun vlog like we're right
now we're asking these [ __ ] what goes
up is there paperwork yeah what do you
have to do
how does that work yeah like interview
one dude going in yo tell us what you
had to do to like walk in like i just
walked in and gave the money
that's all he's gonna say yeah i was way
simpler we just got demonetized yeah so
i mean it's okay though
but for sure
about an hour in here folks
yeah i don't know i just know like is
that legal how are these dudes doing
that [ __ ] and there's like i don't know
there's a show my sister used to watch a
show about a brothel yeah and she's like
air force amy she used to talk about
this [ __ ] all the time
i don't know
i don't know if it's real i don't know
what it is
and are they hookers are they is it a
show i don't know
but that's awesome that you've never
been to strip club and you live in vegas
that's the [ __ ] coolest thing it's
like marty never doing coke or it's sold
okay he's like yo
good for you a lot of uh you i've done
coke and i've been to strip club [ __ ]
i'm the [ __ ] [ __ ] here
but that's okay that's okay damn we went
from music and then straight into
brothels that's terrible
flip
the cards everything in between yeah
dude to the cards on this trip
[Laughter]
school too yeah school was yeah didn't
like school oh yeah we got into school
standing in the stalls yeah
i used to do that [ __ ] we got into yeah
i'm [ __ ] high we got into the music
yeah you're smoking a lot before this so
get off those new dopest principles oh i
know i'm about to smoke it right now oh
okay oh okay um
yeah i'm about to smoke that [ __ ] about
to smoke it
i wanted to get into we got into the
music for everyone out there if you like
it that was your message if you like it
and you think it's gonna
something you really really love and
you're passionate about to keep trying
maybe you'll get played one day i used
to say that if i get paid for this [ __ ]
one day [ __ ] music
keep [ __ ] doing i used to say i used
to say that before we ever made money
ever like if we get paid one day that's
gonna be [ __ ] tight if we don't i
love making videos yeah [ __ ] it
thanks for saying that [ __ ] i mean it's
on video for the longest time i thought
i was actually in the red like not that
i was really looking at it from a
financial perspective but as far as you
know buying the mic paying for beats and
whatnot um i never have paid for a
feature though that's one thing that i
like
just wouldn't do like if you want to
make music with me then we'll make music
but i'm not i know a lot of i'm not
hating on anyone who buys a feature
because some people use it to to try and
gain more of a uh
fan base yeah exactly but like me i was
just like no
i paid for beats and i i feel like
that's different you know you're paying
for someone's work the you know yeah
but as far as like oh you want to be on
my song anyone that i've made music with
has just been out of like either i
wanted a collab they wanted and it was
like a mutual agreement of like both of
us wanting to work no one was getting
paid to do
anything so yeah
so
real quick
yo we were talking about music and how
the [ __ ] do we get on that crazy ass
topic guys to monetize and now we're
back we were talking about vegas and
then stripping okay that's what it was
[ __ ] here we go
i know how i remembered that thank you
live shows
have you ever done live shows yes a
couple how did you like it
how'd you like it um
because you feel like i always stay in
the stalls man you're trying to talk to
[ __ ] then at the stage exactly
it is it is and i felt like
i was telling him in the car earlier but
i'm not sure if it's my i don't want to
like say i can't do it but
i did it one time
well i've done it twice but i'm going to
the first time i did it was in
california i was uh one of the openers
for guap gang which i don't know if you
know they were like guava mizzle go up
lord i've heard it and danny the demon
shout out to danny he was the one who
got that uh whole like books for me and
everything
and most of the people i think there was
like a few people who knew me but like
it was just more of me kind of like
feeling what it was like to be on stage
you know
and then
um it was this the second time was way
better than that
so the second time
um i was one of the headliners and it
was a lot of people in the underground
that i also have made music with i liked
and i have never even met before too and
it was at a it was at a backyard of
someone's house
where you live
no not this was in cat this was actually
in la oh [ __ ] i don't know if i the
first show is in l.a i don't know if i
mentioned that sorry so the first show
was in la but it was at an actual venue
the second one which was better happened
to be
at someone's house in the backyard they
set it up they had it dj the speakers
and the turnout was way better at least
for me like the gwop gang and guap lord
all of them had a great turnout but like
most people were there i was opening for
them and most people were there to see
them as of the second time i performed i
was headlining most people were there to
see me so i had people some people knew
some of my lyrics like when i went to
perform like a lot of people stood up
and it was like whoa i didn't really
expect that and it was a really great
feeling and whatnot and once i got into
it i felt my rhythm and i felt like i
could do it so i don't know but
yeah um i love making music though
it's just performing in front of large
groups of people i don't know if i just
like the whole
i don't know
maybe a few years ago i don't know if
i'm like
just like i don't want to say i'm too
old i'm 23 but like i don't know if like
maybe two years ago i would go in a mosh
pit and have like you know i just don't
know if i'm trying to be in that type of
like [ __ ] intense a different
personality energy do you know what i'm
saying i don't know if i'm like
stumbling over mine no you're saying i
know exactly when you think of all those
crazy concerts i'm not trying to say i'm
anywhere of like juice world and all
those other like insane concerts like
all those like i don't know if i want
that to be like
you know around you around me i'm not
really with that you know okay that's
fine yeah
a lot that might surprise a lot of
people because maybe two three years ago
i would have said otherwise but
no that's not what makes me happy now no
you know that's cool though
so no live shows you don't you don't see
in the near future possibly possibly
but i don't want people to be killing
each other
i i don't know if i want to bring that
like
angry like you know because that's how
it is a lot in the underground and i
have a lot of music songs that are like
that but that's not what i want to
continue going with so
yeah all right that's cool
you see what it could cause
i was always like that i like going it's
not what i was really really aligned
with now that's all like i don't know if
that makes sense but no i totally get it
you might not like just being the center
of attention too is the other thing like
in a room full of people that's a whole
separate i kind of came to that
realization a couple days i was just
telling you we had a conversation in the
car
and as much as i love having a platform
and audience like there are so many
other things in life that make me happy
and
that's not one of it like i want to live
i've known this for a while
that i i really want to live more of a
simple life
but the other day i ate a couple grams
of mushrooms and yeah it just like i've
already known i've already known but
it's solidified it's like yo this
this is what makes you happy you need to
do it
cool
so so at least when i you know what you
want
yeah and if i'm confusing what i mean by
like a simple life is i just
i don't want to be too engulfed in like
the internet and social media my whole
life you know it's a thought upkeep man
yeah it's a [ __ ] full-time job
and then usually when other [ __ ] on the
side so
it's almost like you have no time
i really just see myself
living out in the woods in a small
little house like no [ __ ] like
that's what makes that's where you
that's where you're headed
so are you one of these dudes that are
going to do the van tours i thought
about that
but
i want to buy a house first i think
i think that's more important in vegas
no
we're gonna move
i want i've been thinking it's not
solidified but there's there's places i
want land that's cheap and i want less
restrictions and um just so i can
live my life free and like i know that
sounds corny to a lot of people but
what like what part of this what's the
part of the company so there's a few
places that i'm not solidified on but
i'm keeping in mind
um
tennessee has great
damn you're trying to make the move like
that yeah wow
tennessee tennessee has great land um
resources sunlight i mean the only thing
i haven't done a lot of research so i
don't want to sound like i'm an expert
on all like the what's best for my
situation because one thing i am worried
about is like tornadoes and [ __ ] like
that there's all those things you have
to think about yeah um
texas land is cheap um luke's family is
out there and
like they have a house and i kind of
just like got an idea of what like they
have their own they originally when i
first went and i visited luke and his
family they just had a regular house in
the suburbs of texas they just recently
moved to a house oh i saw the picture
yeah
so they just recently made the move
where they have like their own and i
just kind of saw i was like dude this is
so peaceful
that's all i want i want to walk out in
my balcony and have just [ __ ] trees
woods and
thought about oregon and have my dog
ever thought about oregon i have i'm
just not too keen on the politics out
there so i don't think i could the
politics it's just crazy out there yeah
yeah i'll pay attention i have no idea
these things aren't weed
what are they talking about what's going
on as far as like the weed and
everything but like
i have no idea what's going on
i mean [ __ ] i don't know anything about
anything except for that's been the
epicenter of all the like riots and all
that [ __ ] oh with that [ __ ] yeah okay
well well that's that that's i mean
that's like a small portion but just
like
i can really get into it there's so many
uh as far as like what i'm trying to do
prices are high up there i'm not trying
to [ __ ] spend that much i know it's
beautiful it's one of the most beautiful
states i've been in for sure i'm not
gonna argue that
prices is high lots of restrictions
you know and that's just like the main
thing like there's a lot more
restrictions if you were to compare
trying to like off-grid i'm not trying
to like live in [ __ ]
middle of nowhere you know what i'm
saying but like there's way more
restrictions you can do way more
in like tennessee if you really just
want some [ __ ] land you can do
whatever the [ __ ] you want yeah
that's what it's coming down to i'm
hearing yeah that's all you need okay
it's like okay so tennessee texas the
best i can to start growing my own food
i'd really know nothing about it
obviously i grew up in a [ __ ] house
in the city but
you live you learn maybe i can go like
the food that we eat is [ __ ] i'm not
trying to eat that [ __ ] anymore i'm
trying to go to a local farm where i can
get some good [ __ ]
and
yeah
like that's just kind of the same
all i keep hearing is i know what i want
i have a plan every single thing i'm
hearing so far is like i know exactly
when i want to have a plan
i like it at least you know dude because
most people are a lot i mean i was lost
i'm not going to say i'm not lost now
yeah but
i like that you know what you want i
don't know what the [ __ ] what makes you
happy
you got to figure out where your values
are and what really
and
i don't know like if you were to ask me
a few years like i mean i've known i've
known that i've wanted to live out i
know i've known that i did not want to
live in vegas and i've wanted to live
somewhere where it's more green and but
the one thing that these past few years
of just all the craziness like that
really solidified like
i want to be able to rely on myself and
not to be dependent on governments
corporations because the more you can
rely on yourself the less they can
control you i don't think yes i don't
think these people have our best
interest in mind you know i agree
and that's why i don't pay attention to
anything that happens i just do what i
have to do
it takes a toll on on
like
me personally it's like in a battle of
like i
want to know what's going on but then
over time it just starts
taking a toll of like man this shit's
[ __ ] up and you just gotta [ __ ] get
in yeah you gotta keep you know focusing
on doing the best you can as far as in
your life what you can do for yourself
and
try not to let that [ __ ] bring you down
you know
100 yeah i i try not to like i know it's
like you're ignoring the problem like
[ __ ] [ __ ] you don't you keep bringing it
up man i don't hear that [ __ ] that's
going on just let me just live my
[ __ ] life like
instagram you know like social media
it's like really hard to avoid
yeah it's everywhere
that's one of the reasons i got off
twitter is i used to have twitter
and
i was sick of it like i don't know if i
was following the wrong but just like
[ __ ]
just everywhere i was just seeing all
this and i'm like i do not want to see
this and i just uninstalled the app a
lot of these it's funny because
excuse me a lot of i remember i decided
i was going to uninstall twitter when i
was
in the middle of a mushroom trip oh
this was epiphanies and i'm sitting
there and i'm like this is not
benefiting your life in any way shape or
form like you just go on there and like
i literally
weighed out the benefits and the
negatives in my mind and i thought okay
what is good there's really funny [ __ ]
you see on there that you can't deny
there's some funny ass [ __ ] on twitter
funny memes and funny videos but is it
worth this was a couple years ago i
don't know what that what it is now this
is no i see what you're saying like
is the funniness world is it
all the [ __ ] all the [ __ ] people
telling you how to think what to do this
politics this that shut up don't tell me
what to do go away like also just take
it off these people
want to act like they're the the better
person all the time but really it's like
i see through that of course of course
and you know what i do my favorite thing
to do ever
is to respond and then just block them i
do that a lot it's so funny because like
oh they read it and then when i can't
respond i mean they can't make it
[ __ ] i wanted to say i love it or on
instagram my favorite thing to do is
someone's being a dick is i respond and
then i restrict them so they can't
comment without me approving so they
they're commenting comedy comedy and
they're in there's like why isn't it
working is it giving them why is it
working i'm not blocked
it's like comment won't load or whatever
yeah
it's just
is my connection
good i don't think i've no i've never
been i know that was an option i
i just do the blog i say i respond i let
them read it and then i block when i
want them to see the whole car like when
they say something and i say something
back
it's never rude i'm always [ __ ] on
somebody politely for the most part
and i love it when it's just like oh
yeah
you take
restrict and then everybody below damn
that guy's a [ __ ] idiot man that
guy's an [ __ ] this guy's just
losing it at home i love making
[ __ ] feels exactly and something to
specif specify it's [ __ ] it's not
just it you have no it's [ __ ] yeah
you have to be the same stating your
opinion is fine exactly if you said it
politely you could say i really don't
like anything simplify this it's really
easy to tell if someone's being like you
know you could switch someone's being
you know what i'm saying but like for
the most part you can tell so you know
what i did the other day
what more he's talking about first off
i'm [ __ ] high you look
[ __ ] up too that's what i'm here for
yeah he looks high as [ __ ] so
i did the video when i bought marty the
watch and i did a video i wanted to call
it i bought a rolex
to bait all the [ __ ] people that are
super rude and [ __ ] to go you're a
[ __ ] [ __ ] buying [ __ ] dude
oh yeah
if you were to listen eight seconds in
the video this is for marty as a present
i just wouldn't want it but i bought
martial rolex because then
people that wanted to be dicks are gonna
be hidden but the people that wore dicks
and went oh okay cool come out come
blocked you got your ass blocked you
[ __ ] you it just makes me like you
didn't even watch it you were just
[ __ ] negative to begin with why are
you here you're not anymore
i did a little bait trick the other day
it worked
so it made me laugh
that's what i like to do i don't like to
start argument to just go
please get away from me just go go about
your day i used to engage it's like you
can't you can't waste your energy it's
so pointless
just because most when you really look
at it most of these people are not
really in a good place no you have to
know that like yeah because you would
never go on someone's page and start
being a dick no you're a normal person
who who does that people that are sad
and [ __ ] mad at this their life
and i don't want to make it worse by
going you know you're a piece of [ __ ]
but sometimes i do exactly and there's a
difference between
criticizing and yeah
you can
give your two cents if it's
polite you can even say the negative
[ __ ] if you said it polite hey not to be
offensive but i really don't like this i
think you should try that like all right
that's cool i won't but i you know your
opinion that comment that's cool and a
lot of prizes you do get that like
comment where it is constructive
criticism a lot of times it's actually
good advice sometimes it's good like oh
[ __ ] you're right yeah exactly all right
all right that's fine but when someone's
just being an [ __ ] you like it you
could tell
and uh i won't stand for it
i will not fly i don't have the time to
do that i'm good um
oh my god i am fun can i interject a
quick fan question here oh yeah go for
it what's up
at dope as usual podcast
[ __ ] again let's see what we got
here a lot of lot a lot of glass
questions glass oh it's because this
like i said the reason i got that super
dope bong is because of brandon
okay he brought his bombs over you guys
saw the video smoke out with raw og
uh-huh that's when i got hooked
so we got we got colin franchu we got
marky mark 97
asking about
your most important
glass piece
slash most expensive
so my my most favorite slash most
expensive piece
your favorite sl or your most expensive
or both
so
it's really like a lot of people are
going to get mad because it's really
hard to pick because i recycle through
my pieces all the time i might hit like
five different pieces a day sometimes
maybe one month i might go through a
phase where i'm really liking this piece
and then the next month i start hitting
this piece more but as of recently the
180 grid which i actually brought oh
that one okay that one
um it's definitely not my most expensive
but just something about the straight
straight hit
it's simple
also i think this has a lot to do with
it my first ever sovereignty i bought
was a 180 grid and it was from luke it's
not that one but i have another one
that's pretty much identical it's just
different color
so i bought that one from luke and i
think it's just the sentimental value
like luke is my brother and like i just
hit that piece all the time it was the
first piece i got me hooked so i love
that piece
um and then the most expensive piece
that i've bought is between
the hams
my two hams pieces i believe
and the swiss perk
the swiss perk is like you know what
that is yeah ham's uh ham's water works
is like i have this recycler i don't
know if how much is that you know what a
recyclable of course the rig though um
anywhere between a thousand to two
thousand okay so and the reasonable
glass yeah
he's the one who's the first glassblower
to ever make a recycler so like he has
really yeah he's been doing this [ __ ]
for a while he has a lot of recognition
he's very respected throughout a lot of
what's his name
ham's waterworks
you invented the recycler yes what is
that the first it's the style of rig it
could be a bong too but the way the
water comes back and recycles back down
and funnels through itself it's like a
never-ending you have a lot of glass
blower i'm just i'm sure you've hit yeah
before you've hit one before here
let me see your rig i mean let me see
the bong underneath your desk so yeah i
have the hurricane perk which is a
recycler
and then the aqua duck which a lot of
people say kind of looks like a pumpkin
you may have seen it oh yeah it's like
that little balls looking piece
he made that as well and that's one of
his he doesn't make those as often like
he numbers all his pieces
and uh to put into perspective i believe
for every like
five hurricane perks recyclers he makes
like one aqueduct and the aqueduct is
like a working yes and i yeah i was got
one of those really luckily shout out to
gorilla radio and luke they
have you know they've really luke has
taught me so much and then mark at
guerrilla radio
is the glass shop that's the name of it
gorilla radio is the glass shop that
luke works at that luke works
i mean obviously rage against the
machine is that yes
i don't i'm not too familiar i asked
mark as the owner
and he said it's a music band
like that's what it's
so i believe what you just said is
probably it i'm not sure though i could
be completely [ __ ] up okay i'm mixing
up bands right now but mark mark is
awesome he's helped me get so many nice
pieces and
you know he's just like
he's such a nice guy like come back and
chill in the shop with them and
dab in the back and
it's a great time fun times yeah
especially at the glass shop
sick class shop do you mainly dab
i mainly take bong rips it's mainly
flour but i do dab i've been getting
into flower more since the rosin i know
rosin's been hyped for a while now but
i'd say the past couple months i've been
dabbing more um shout out to swank
genetics and iron bay hash that shit's
bomb as [ __ ] he's out in vegas and the
one i smelled earlier yes yeah stupid
fire
it was uh some motor breath that you
smelled which is like an og cross and
just ever since linking up with him and
having access to
that bomb ass [ __ ] hash and a lot of
it like i can get it right when it's
freshly pressed so i like put in the
freezer and then like dude it's the best
way to go you get the wine cooler
i i don't have that yet i need to get
one of these i just keep it in my screen
okay with a freezer i for some reason i
feel like it gives moisture i don't know
why i keep it in a bag to try and put a
bag in the parchment yeah yeah i don't
know why i feel like it changes it i
could be tripping you're probably right
i could be tripping though but
i just found it to be better in the wine
cooler but yeah ever since i started
yeah he comes crazy with his ninja dabs
you sesh with him uh that
i've seen these videos the videos you
guys and eric is eric know this person
yes eric has been there as well
hangs out with him all the time as well
yeah he's a mutual friend oh yeah he'll
come with like a gram dude and when
you're taken off the slurper no the trip
server's against you for everyone out
there terrorist slurper to me it's just
like a beer bong with alcohol
it's like that it's just shotgunning
[ __ ] down yes i love it ever since i
tried one i went and i got myself a bear
quartz which is
there's a lot of super expensive boujee
banger like you know you already know i
got like one of the 80 ones i need a new
banger i need something so i just need
something that's going to work
and it's good quartz is not i mean you
can air quartz air quartz is like i
think like under a hundred dollars you
can definitely spend a couple hundred
get like a quave or
something that's the only other one i
know
yeah and then there's a
there's i can't think of names um if
luke was sitting here next to me he'd be
like boom boom boom boom boom boom boom
he's like really knowledgeable about it
like he helped me buy mine not even half
the knowledge of him when it comes to
like heady glass but
yeah i need to get another one for sure
i know that you want another solve i
need to get it for somebody yeah okay
i might be getting a mother ship soon
uh my friend got a uh
[ __ ] it called an account you get an
account with mothership a wholesale
account but the whole uh we'll see it's
story time orange
all right we'll see we'll see if i get
it but guys i'm gonna say right now the
cold ass air in here
the fact that i've been up since five
and the amount of weed ever smoked i
feel like
just a little like eight
yeah
so we're gonna watch half-baked to fall
asleep i feel like i'm in high school
right now i am [ __ ] genuinely high
you hit me up at the perfect time where
my sleep schedule was ideal
you were telling me like
i'm going to sleep on a good time my
shit's always going all over the place
and right now it's like steady where i'm
going to sleep at like 9 10 waking up
like 7 8 like but for the past few days
and i'm trying to keep it sick and this
i've gone through this cycle so many
times already where i have yeah it's
called life yeah it's exactly i [ __ ]
up it's been eight months since i've you
know sleep schedule oh my god yeah it
happens it is and it happens
i know like barney's going hard over
there oh yeah i got the [ __ ] dober's
pre-roll oh you got it at the table
you're good you're good oh dude it gets
[ __ ] okay so we just dropped these
like we talked about the dopest pre-roll
um for everyone out there uh my
billboards their billboards went up
yesterday and today
if you're anywhere near the lax on
century boulevard look for my high-ass
face on that big giant story time orange
billboard
or if you're in carson california on the
side it's a pretty populated area you
it's
one
know you picked me up from the airport
and he's like yo i gotta show you
something it's the it's the way out yeah
it's the way it's the way out of the
airport
and you mentioned i don't know if you
want to say anything but you already
said it's like so far so good right oh
yeah dude we already had spike in
traffic yeah i bet yeah
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] 10 million people just
drove past that it's crazy
like what the hell is this and they're
all going off to different parts of the
country and [ __ ] yeah i love that that's
true so smart to put it right there
that's true but for a lot of people like
we were talking about it
it just tastes like weed
it tastes like a regular pre-roll yeah
of course once i finish this just kind
of try it yeah it's just kind of odds
like does it taste super far but it
tastes like weed
you know it's like like it tastes like a
pre-roll you get from the store
that's it yeah
it's so odd yeah but it's like
illegal legally
yeah
legal in your town now
it's crazy yeah it's so perfect for all
the people who don't have a plug like
you're in like [ __ ] missouri or some
[ __ ]
at least it's something you know i mean
you could just be having nothing
you have another side but like i was
telling you earlier california is one of
our biggest ones because people are
[ __ ] with it dude they're curious
dude they also want to support you yes
that yes and the edibles the edibles
really actually get you from you told a
story where you like the [ __ ]
i know there's so much though it's like
i don't know if it was on a podcast or a
[ __ ] video or whatever
sometimes i forget wait where i tell
that oh yeah that's right twitter i'm
like that as well yeah it's too much
marty what time we are now
1 30. nice nice nice
question
have you ever gotten any backlash for
having this channel
whether it be family
uh not being able to rent a [ __ ] spot
because they were like oh hell no we've
seen this [ __ ] uh not being able
to buy a car or something because you
don't have no the income no i've been
pretty slick with it as far like when
you
because you mentioned so many different
like ways so as far as like
getting a car like how like i've never
really
like when i so i just moved out of my
dad's house um just about a year ago and
when i was like you know you got to go
through the whole process of like
incoming all that i was just putting my
um clothing brand and whatnot so i
didn't really say anything about my
youtube so i i don't try to put myself
in a position to get back to have to
talk about it as far as close family
like
uh by the time like my mom and dad found
out i was already like
doing good so like they couldn't really
you know
do anything yeah um
and
they do support me they believe as long
as i'm happy and i'm
you know making money and
doing what i want yeah i mean they're
cool with it and as i think you know
most
parents should be as long as your kid's
not
doing some stupid [ __ ] i don't know
yeah
as long as they're making something of
themselves man every question i had that
i did not expect the answer marty you're
a machine you rolled like four joints
already yeah
uh
here we go i got another one i got
another one ready
mushrooms
let's talk about them
your shirt for everyone out there that
doesn't know what's going on probably
hasn't seen it can you show them yeah
it's your that's your shout out to
amanda she killed this design
that's your from high high
spirit
dot co dot co
exactly so what's up with the lemon tag
explain the shirt
so lemon tech and i also want to get
into
i'll just get into it after okay so
lemon tech
is a way that you can consume mushrooms
i don't know how long it's been around
but people like it's
you pretty much grind up your mushrooms
into the finest form you can powder
whatever
um some people take like lemon juice
from the bottle i prefer
actual lemons i take lemons cut them up
you take the ground mushrooms in like a
shot cup or a cup you
squeeze the lemon juice over
the powder over the powder and like so
it's fully submerged you mix it up and
then it's going to be like this kind of
weird consistency like a wet mud yeah
like a wet mud you let it sit for 20 30
minutes so probably wondering like why
the [ __ ] do you do this so the idea
behind lemon tag i don't know if it's
scientifically proven is
is
there's a ph like you know how lemons
are acidic
it's a it's somewhere in the same levels
as your stomach so they believe that
you're pulling out the silicon which is
that uh active ingredient in psilocybin
so it's like pre-digesting it in a way
so by the time you take it
it kicks in quicker and i can say by
experience i don't know if it's placebo
but man every and i've taken mushrooms a
lot every time i started doing lemon
teching
it's like 30 the 45 minute mark instead
of like i'm like going up it's usually
less less nausea because i've
experienced
you get nausea lemon tech helps with
nausea and then you also have a more
smooth come down so ever since
mindful micronut uh he's the one who
the calendar is on the website if you've
ever seen them all the crazy [ __ ]
mushrooms oh the calendar you just gave
me yeah the calendar i gave you please
check it out hi spirit all his mushrooms
as well dude he kills it his genetics
his genetics are insane he's been
working on them for years to get them
isolated the perfect monoculture and not
just one he's done different crosses and
he's also a brother to me like
i love him so like he's he's awesome but
back to the mushrooms the lemon tech um
it's just ever since he put me on to it
he's like hey you got to try this way of
consuming mushrooms i love it i do it
all the time because i've had issues
with nausea and yeah you just take it
like in a shot just i've never even
heard of this before then like drink
water after because it's like super sour
marty i gave him four grams and did
nothing to him it took uh it took a
minute yeah i had to work and then two
more times didn't do nothing and then
one smash the [ __ ] the chocolate bar
[ __ ] him up but try lemon text maybe
this yeah
yeah no should i will use the grinder
uh-huh write them down so as far as this
design i it's just something like i
well now i get it if you know you know
you look at oh
have made a great
like a great impact on my life
so
it's a way of saying thanks to this
sacred medicine you know so like
lemon tech is the way i like to consume
the mushrooms so amanda the artist i
pretty much had the idea i got
with most of my designs i i come up with
the concept like i have an idea in my
hand probably just as you do with push
through a little sketch
i
there's still a picture of this sketch
to this day it's so shitty keep all of
them that's yeah i have the sketches so
for sure
it's so tricky i pretty much wear like i
want like a lemon with like some
mushrooms and then
the lemon lemon tech over it but in the
lemon font of like the lemon juice you
know if you recognize this is the same
font
so i did that and that's how the design
came out now when you first asked me
this and i said i wanted to speak about
something else because i've had so many
people be like oh i've seen lemon tech
is that your lemon tech because have you
seen those bottles
that people i don't know if you've seen
them they're apparently they're popping
i had no idea i just recently found out
but there's these bottles that someone
is making and they're uh calling them
lemontec which is completely cool um
they're just it's some lemonade mixture
and i assume they're taking like ground
mushroom powder but a lot of people are
associating that with me and thinking
that
like i have no problem with the dude at
all like he's killing it probably it's
awesome probably good mushrooms i don't
know
um but
i just don't want people to think i'm
copying or it's like no lemon tech is a
technique it's a technique and it's been
around for longer this dude just as i'm
as capitalizing on like
like i think i want capitalizing if
that's the right word i'm just taking
the cool concept just as he is but he's
making uh his own little thing out of it
with me i'm just like taking the design
it's just yeah it's not
it's how i take my mushrooms as well so
it's not just like coming out of my ass
you know so
yeah lemon tech all the way
so
for me like i was telling you i take
about seven grams every time like when i
really really really do mushrooms but i
do by myself i've never taken i think
the most i've taken is five sorry to
interrupt oh you're bro that's what the
show's about
we just keep talking high oh i promise
you when you watch your back you're
gonna go
and i did that probably five times yeah
marty you're smiling yeah yeah he does
yeah he does
my bad i'm sorry i [ __ ] i'm high and
rambling um
have you ever taken mushrooms in the
dark and just yes
how did you like it
i can tell you a weird experience where
i didn't even take that much
so
i think this was 2019 yes it was 2019 of
july for the fourth of july oh do you
remember that way yeah you remember the
month yeah because
i was i was in washington for the fourth
of july
and i took some mushrooms and i ended up
going to sleep that like going to bed
that night at the house i was staying at
and i wasn't like obviously i took the
mushrooms i wasn't tired i'm laying in
the bed it's just complete
darkness like this room was just as dark
as it gets and as i'm laying in there
i didn't have the most insane visuals
but i started hearing like these little
like these little like elf
and i didn't know if i was tripping if i
was like if someone is there a tv but
like i even went and opened the door and
no everyone's asleep
i close the door and i like go and i lay
back down and it's like in my head
though and i'm hearing these little
elves like laughing and i didn't even
eat that much it was like a gram and a
gram and a half
and it was
where i open my uh eyes or close them
and it's that dark so
yeah it doesn't matter it doesn't matter
this room i found out when there's no
lights on is that room okay the other
day when they turn the electricity off
yeah to do this oh [ __ ] sorry
so you heard elves did you scream i
don't know i can't i don't know what an
elf sounds like because i've never met
one but it
that's what i assume an elf
it's what your brain would assume that's
what my brain would assume
that was amazing so politically correct
well
you know i don't want to say what they
sound like that was amazing that was the
politically correct way i wasn't even
think because i'm normally not
politically correct but i was just like
just thinking like damn if that's where
they even sound like political
correctness now is like [ __ ]
[ __ ] like it makes me want to live off
grid yeah it's like [ __ ] like
it doesn't even make sense anymore like
people just [ __ ] virtue signaling for
no reason
i
don't pay attention so [ __ ] much yeah
good job that that [ __ ] doesn't even
affect me good job like was i offensive
was i well not to me are you a good
person indeed like are you a good guy
come on your feelings what's wrong with
you i would never call you that
oh i called you that [ __ ] i'm sorry
i didn't know you went by she or him
that thing confuses me because i don't
know
yeah because i have my i have some
people that go that really are that and
that's fine like that's what you really
[ __ ] with like no i pronounce you this
this and that like bro if you think i'm
gonna remember
i'll try my [ __ ] best to remember
you know what i mean because i have some
friends that are trans i know some no
and then it's like she that's right i
gotta say she i gotta remember because
no that's what she wants to be called
now i get it
i get it when it's super important it's
like no you better and one of the things
that i don't understand which a lot of
people might hate on me but i don't
understand that they
they them one i don't because it sounds
plural to me yeah i don't know i know
people but it's genuinely me not
understanding like yeah i've never
explained this stuff to me and it's not
like i'm like if someone wants to
explain it explain it get someone in the
comments
there you ready
thank you some of the comments explain
this to us so we know what to make it
makes sense make it make sense for us
because like i said when it's important
and i know it's like no i make it a turn
like i always say you know when you say
you're not sure someone's name you go
stay in your head first and then you say
it you just stay in your head i hate
when that happens because when you meet
someone then you don't want to feel like
a dick yeah you don't want to feel like
don't [ __ ] up
thank you sometimes i just be straight
up and honestly i'm like hey man i
really forgot and sometimes people they
don't really get because you don't want
to be like come across as a dick like
hey i forgot your name but some
just try to come across as honestly also
everybody's high as [ __ ] sometimes i
forget
that's all sometimes we forget and it's
not it's not like trying to be rude
thinking anything yeah
especially confused somebody help us out
with you so many people
i'm sure
i meet a lot of people on it i don't i
can't speak for you but like when i go
to different
sessions and whatnot different
um glass events and whatnot dude you're
meeting so many different people and
sometimes it's really hard to like just
oh this person but then some people
stick out really well you know like oh i
remember you for sure but it's just
[ __ ] hard and it makes me like i
don't want to feel rude i want to be
rude to you
that's my thing i don't want you to
think i'm a rude person like i don't
give a [ __ ] i just don't i don't
remember i'm sure as a kid you remember
you had teachers like all right it's
going to take me a while to get you
ready remember i used to think like how
like what the [ __ ] i'm brandon like how
do you not know me but as i get older
it's like no i totally understand where
they're coming there's a lot of people
they know
we only know our [ __ ] two friends
yeah and our mom
what's up guys welcome to the mid-roll
ad read and this ad read is sponsored by
betterhelp betterhelp is an online
service that pairs you with actual
license therapists it's not a draw of
the hat you're not just randomly getting
somebody there's questions you have to
be asked for you to match up because
this is professional this is actually
real before i continue i wanted to say
that it's not a crisis hotline this is a
thing that you work on gradually mental
health is just like physical health it's
not overnight better help is online
phone chat or live chat say you're a shy
person you don't want to be sitting live
chat you can just do a phone
conversation and depending on where you
go this is way more affordable than
seeing an hourly therapist if this
interests you at all guys if you even
want to check out some information go to
betterhelp.com betterhelp.com use the
code check out dope if you decide to use
it that's 10 off your first month of
therapy as i said before we took on this
brand sponsorship because we hope it can
help and since we've been doing this we
have gotten
hundreds if not more people saying thank
you so much for introducing this to me
so thank you so much for supporting and
allowing us to get sponsors but also
we're stoked that it's actually helping
so once again guys go to betterhelp.com
forward slash dope or use dope as the
checkout that's 10 off your first month
as always guys thank you so much for
supporting the brands that support us
back to the episode yeah so how the [ __ ]
do we keep getting these topics okay
ready go mushrooms that's where we were
yeah we keep going i'm sorry oh no it's
fine but we're like trying to real real
is back in i'm i'm [ __ ] high
ready
mushrooms yes you'll love them you've
been taking them when is the first trip
you said
the first trip i didn't have a good time
not where it was like a bad trip where i
was like traumatized or anything um
because
as i mentioned i used to get
i don't have i sometimes get nausea but
not as much
i got the first time i took it was with
brando
his name just keeps getting brought up i
took mushrooms with him and it was 1.5
we split an eighth so like 1.7 whatever
and we made a t out of it split the t
and he was having a great time i was a
junior so this was like right after i
started smoking weed
um
and i just remember going in my backyard
and laying on the grass
but no i was like nauseous like laying
there trying to like
try to throw up trying not to throw up
like i was just laying there and i
started
having like when i look back
i didn't really realize it at the time
but i had a lot of different like things
that i was coming to my mind and
thinking about and things like but i was
so focused on the nausea that i didn't
really have a good time so my first time
it wasn't a because when people say i
didn't have a good time most people
immediately think oh you had like a
a bad trip second time i took it again
didn't just
nauseating the third time i was with a
group of people and for some reason it
just hit right that time i didn't get
nauseous and i finally got the
experience of
psilocybin and then as time goes on now
i
the last time i ever took mushrooms
was with someone was with my boy hunter
and i actually had to think about this
like
when's the last time that i actually
took mushrooms with stone because it's
been such a long time using them alone
all the time yeah
i take them alone all the time the one
the person i talk about is hunter he's
also my brother who lives in arizona um
not my actual brother but a really close
friend and we watched malcolm in the
middle that was like
that show was great
and you watched last year's i mean last
week's show no is that why you brought
that up no what about what
marty over here has never seen malcolm
in the middle
do you like that show it's one of the
best shows ever okay because i thought
when you said a i was about to be hurt
because that's one of my favorite shows
dude
we watched it while we were watching it
while we were tripping it's so good i
was trying to explain it to marty like
yo now that i get older and watch it
it's pretty adult there's some adult
[ __ ]
jokes in there from hal and lois yeah
that i never really got as a kid
you get it so your kids will love it
you'll love it april love it's a good
show i got a couple comments so yeah
cause we told him last time like hey
everybody go comment marty go watch
[ __ ] malcolm in the middle that's
what we talked about last episode i'm
like go watch it how's the dog
he's so it's just
and then you watch breaking bad
afterwards no
he's untwisted push down oh sorry now
you're good it's like how do i open this
dude
he's never seen you have to watch it
it's one of my favorite yeah
it's one of my favorite shows of all
time it's so good episode one down to
[ __ ] the last one it's so and it came
out my fourth grade year the fourth
grade years where i got kicked out of my
regular class and i had to go to the
smart kid class
exactly what happened to him i'm like
wow whoa that's me
that's me oh can i calculate numbers in
my house you got put in those class the
i was in the gate it's called okay i
remember that i was never in [ __ ] i
really wanted to be because yeah
we got a pizza party that was all it was
at the end of the year [ __ ] that [ __ ]
yeah more homework but a pizza party
[ __ ] out of here eight dollars a pizza
for more homework for the year
but yeah malcolm in the middle malcolm
in the middle like yeah we were watching
that but
back to the mushrooms thing nowadays
i'll still eat mushrooms like with a
close friend and have a great time you
can eat them like as much as i respect
the sacred medicine for
using it for personal development and
whatever you need to figure out within
yourself you can also have a really good
time with some good friends i don't want
to be one of those dudes who like no you
can only eat it too like i hate that
[ __ ] yeah you know you can have it for
you if it's for you that's like whatever
but for me recently i found great use in
taking it by myself um
how i kind of have like a ritual that i
do whenever i take my mushrooms like
let me hear it okay so
what i've been doing the past few years
is years how much do you take mushrooms
how long often do you take past couples
how often do you take since i since okay
so i said it the first time it wasn't a
good time second time wasn't a good time
third time finally had a good time ever
since then throughout and it's not like
i take them all the time it's whenever i
feel the need whenever i have my calling
um i'd say two three years ago i had
like a a few months where i was like
really going into it like one time i
took
i think five and a half grams which for
me was like quite a bit i didn't have a
tolerance at the time because you build
a tolerance i took it on a fresh
tolerance and i took in like a smoothie
and that time i was just so i i can't
even go back and oh i learned this like
no i was just so high i was in like
alien world i didn't even know what was
happening i was
sitting there with my good friend sam
and my dad was like my dad knew i was
tripping at the time and we were all
sitting and he was watching a show
and we came and
sat on the couch and watched it with him
and i was staring at the tv for like an
hour not having an idea of what the [ __ ]
was going on just like
like just like
i was just but i wasn't letting it like
[ __ ] with me i knew i was like i'm just
[ __ ] out of it that was that but
back to how i normally take it in my
ritual um
if i'm just taking a regular cube which
is nothing like super strong you have
like penis envies apes which is the
albino penis envies and then there's
other stronger variations true albino
teacher you can get really [ __ ] up off
of those
so when it comes to standard cubes it's
like 3.5 for me lemon tech and how i
normally
and then for sorry and then for penis
envies and those nothing more than
really two grams that's where i'm at
right now i've taken enough mushrooms to
know which strains [ __ ] you up too much
and
did you hear this yeah he's going in
yeah
so
um
it will also penis and because everyone
knows those are stronger it's not just
like i didn't know that penis mushrooms
no those are strong
um
so i
normally i just go and i sit down like
when
when i was at my dad's house and i just
had like my room at my desk i'd sit down
in my desk chair but now that i have my
house i do in my living room i'll just
play some type of music some type of
just like meditation frequency or just
something like natural sound something
really basic just go on youtube time i
put something like that on
and um i go and i prep the lemon tech
and as i'm prepping it i'm just like
taking deep breaths like thinking about
like what am i
wanting to get out of this what am i
gonna do
um
oh you really use mushrooms for a
medicine i yeah i just wanna see crazy
things yeah
this is i like the way you do it i like
that
that sounds like you're using it for a
purpose for me because there's some
things i need to work out
and get that
and um
so as i'm prep i prep the lemons and
while the lemons are soaking i it says
20 minutes 25 but i usually let it just
for like 30 30 i don't know if that does
anything
and while that's soaking i'm just
listening to that music and i'm
breathing i'm just meditating and by the
time of like 30 minutes of just deep
breathing i'm in like a state where i'm
confident i'm like i'm not going to get
nauseated like i feel that confidence
like i
i feel prepped and i take it and then i
go right back into my eyes are closed
breathing into my breathing patterns and
then you just slowly feel and that's how
i've noticed with the lemon tech it
[ __ ] comes quick i think that what's
helped with my nausea is the breathing
um i also didn't even mention i get
really high before this i take lots of
bone grips and i try not to take bone
grips during the come up because during
the come up is when i have the most
your most um
what's the word
susceptible to being nauseous during the
comeback once you're like there i feel
like you're good it's just me personally
do you agree
i get like eight ten minutes of like so
i don't go away rips because that'll
trigger that gag reflex and i've thrown
up a couple times because of that so if
so if anything i
if i'm in a smoke while i'm coming up i
dab because the dab cough doesn't
trigger that gag reflex in a different
way yeah so i do that and i just [ __ ]
breathe and i will sit there and work my
mind because it's not a visual thing for
me it's mind and i sit there and
a lot of things will be some things i
want to work out and i
sometimes take it far as have a list i
don't go crazy i'll just like write like
three words and i know what i'm talking
about in my mind like i know myself
and then um sometimes the mushrooms will
go somewhere else and they'll like no
you need to learn about this instead
and they
and i pretty much once i
feel like i've worked out everything and
i've got the benefit then i'll kind of
like
like what i did last time i started
watching ufc i was like like watching
ufc is like on much after and i feel
like i've learned and like a lot of
times i cry a lot like at least the last
few times i've taken mushrooms it gets
like emotional because i
under like uh
it's hard
are you what you're saying yeah
mushrooms are
a flush
i feel like i'm scared to [ __ ] take
them now why just cause like i've been
going through so much [ __ ] it's like
on one hand it's like you want to take
them to help you get through [ __ ] but on
the other hand it's like i'm really not
that i just got a lot going on mentally
yeah no you gotta
yeah
you it's like a balance if you don't
want to go in there when you're in a
really bad state of mind but
it's like if things aren't going so good
and you can maybe build yourself the
courage to do it i can't speak for
everyone else yes because sometimes
mushrooms will
make it worse for some people and i
don't want to scare people or
but for me it's like i've never i've
never gone through a tough trip and not
came out of it and regretted there's
like
like there's things you learn and then
you look back
and it's a great like it's a it's a
tough learning experience
you know just because like
it's not always a bad trip
i'm trying to think of the right words
to say sorry just because you it's it's
only bad if you learn nothing
um and it was scary i don't know
here's what i'm trying to say sorry guys
there's a difference between a bad trip
and a challenging trip
if that makes sense
a challenging trip is like sometimes you
might face some things you don't want to
go through you might learn and you
and you but you come out of it and you
learn and you
can integrate it what not
and then you have experiences where bad
where it's like oh i was in [ __ ] hell
and like that's what i think when people
say like bad trips and [ __ ] like that
where it's like bro you like really
something in your brain is not the back
chemical balance is not working with the
mushrooms and totally understand that
that's when i like think a bad trip i
don't know if that's like going over the
extent but like no what you said makes
sense it's bad bad and challenging a lot
of bad trips uh stem from
everyone knows this sentence setting
obviously if you're gonna be around a
bunch of people that are and you may not
even at the time know where weirdos but
you'll find out oh you will find the
[ __ ] out you'll find out
and then
what's the other thing
i just had in my mind and i forgot i
could never imagine being around people
while tripping on mushrooms like i just
it's just a different experience you can
feel people's energy
yeah you know 100 i like it you see that
mask that they put on and you see right
the [ __ ] through it
um
i remember when i went outside for the
first time i looked up in the sky and i
was like oh there you guys are to the
stars like oh it's like i've never seen
you before i remember having that just
in my backyard like
having that moment where this i went out
and i looked up in the sky and they were
all
glistening like diamonds i was like oh
how the [ __ ] have i never noticed the
stars he's just his first mushroom ship
was what five months ago yeah oh yeah he
just just was like i think i'll try him
i'll try him so i gave him some i was
just under the impression when he said
you've never taken him before but you've
no he just started taking them the other
day okay gotcha yeah or the other day a
couple months ago and uh i could also
recommend micro dosing if you don't want
to fully dive in micro dosing uh the
ones that i took with you
i gave him some of those yeah yeah so
that's what he's tried so uh the
mushroom vlog i did on we two was the
same exact bottle oh i never even
finished it [ __ ] up like seven people
those ones were awesome
i remembered what i was thinking
okay so one of the things that i think a
lot of people have bad trips is not
being able to surrender is letting
because a lot of people want to fight it
i feel like they don't like the feeling
you have to let go you just have to
let and that's a weird way to put it and
it's hard it's easier
let go yes the feeling of like don't
worry you're going to whatever is going
to happen
yes
embrace it let it happen the only time i
really did that is when i [ __ ] did
that [ __ ] where i was floating above my
body in my [ __ ] house and i was like
flying around my neighborhood so you
were astral projecting and [ __ ] oh the
only time just on mushrooms yeah i've
never had anything to experienced
and then the no
rosie took him with me she took seven
also laid in the bed next to me we
didn't talk
no lights no music the only light was a
couple like headlights that peek through
the blinds on the street across so i was
hearing music
i could feel like i was sweating like
buckets buckets and i swear to god i was
like my back was arching so much i get
sweaty too it felt like your palms get
sweaty my whole body was dripping sweat
and then i just
and i'm above myself and i'm i can see
my own body
and i move my body
and i can see my body move too
at the same time like my hands
like you're like floating i was looking
above and looking going wow with my feet
like
what though i can see my feet move under
the blankets and like all that [ __ ] i
was actually looking have you ever had a
lucid dream
um
my whole life is like that i'm losing my
dreams are [ __ ] i have insane dreams i
have some weird dreams i've had a lucid
dream twice in the first place that's it
yeah i've re i would love to they sound
so fun like as a kid i used to control
my dreams it was food when i was a kid
i had one lucid dream
how far did you fly i didn't it wasn't
like that i tried
um
as far as i remember
this is okay you know how dreams are
random so when i'm speaking be like what
the [ __ ] did you dream that for it's
completely random so i was in my garage
as a little kid doing something and some
girl she's probably like 15 at this time
i'm like five years old at the time
dream so like some big girl comes up i'm
gonna kick your ass or like some [ __ ]
and i
ran inside the house and started running
upstairs
and then something inside me was like
this isn't real and then i go into my
backyard
and there's a [ __ ] lion in my
backyard and i'm like i'm not like i i
was kind of scared but you knew
yeah and then like this was me like
there was an ostrich
and so my i was like i don't want to i i
was scared though and i didn't want to
be in this dream so i was like how do i
get in this
i might my mind i go i either fight the
ostrich or i fight the lion
i don't want to fight the line so i let
the ostrich or whatever the big bird
thing [ __ ]
i don't even i just ran and i woke up i
from what i don't think it like beat me
but like that's
really weird huh
yeah
really weird that was the first lucid
dream i had and then the second one was
probably three years ago
where i was back at my dad's house but
for some reason my mom was in the
kitchen
and i just
looked at her and somehow i knew his
room i looked and i said this is a dream
and then i woke up
okay
really weird i used to be able to
control all my dreams at night as a kid
like think of a place
and then i'd be there why would i fall
asleep
it was real
fun
i kind of forget about it it's like some
peter pan [ __ ] yeah grow up
me and rosie we first started dating
dreams are hard to remember the only
reason i can go so in-depth with those
because i woke up thinking about it like
oh yeah because like i remember like
when you're when you're aware and it
like it's different it senses yeah in my
dreams as a kid i remember the hulk when
he used to jump over canyons and [ __ ] in
the movie i would do like i've done that
in my name i've had dreams where i'm in
my neighborhood just jumping jumping
see none of this was on mushrooms but
yeah that's what the mushroom strips
were like wow oh yeah that's what we
were talking about tangents man dude so
i'm above my body looking at myself
and i [ __ ] blast off of the stars in
the space and [ __ ] it was [ __ ] insane
and i talked
there's a bunch of stuff i won't get
into on camera but i
talked to a bunch of people i want to
hear it after yes for certain it was it
was [ __ ] insane
it was the most wild night i've ever had
and i have not taken more than an eighth
since that day
that was six years ago still well that's
like beyond the heroism
i believe like plus five is i don't know
the exact there's scales and [ __ ]
whatever i'm not ready to go back yeah
there was
it's another level for sure
for me it's all about like yo can we fly
for mushrooms like the way you do it
sounds [ __ ] amazing that sounds like
a lot of people are like the way i do
therapeutic
since there's no one with me and i'm
just meditating like there's nothing but
to dive inward so you better be ready
because a lot of goals exactly
my phone like even if i try to like it's
hard i can't even look i tried to take a
dab with my
terp slurper and you know how it's like
you gotta dunk it i couldn't do it i
stopped i couldn't try i was like no
it's too many steps two minutes and this
was just two days ago i took two grams
of penis envy and that was a [ __ ]
intense one because like two grams penis
envy is almost like
equivalent maybe stronger depending on
what you're taking who grew it uh then
like 3.5 of like a golden teacher or a
standard cube
cube cubensis damn yeah
it's [ __ ] confusing to me all these
names right now like [ __ ] this is
just just sisters
whenever i say cube or cubensis that's
just the most standard magic mushroom
the regular dried up the baby yes just
regular um and obviously there's many
other variations but as far as just to
keep it simple and then you have like
different penis envy so i've never tried
those maybe this is crazy maybe eating
one of these ones is what's the
strongest mushroom that i know there's
like the cyanescence i don't think
that's even a cube it's just a different
um type of magic mushroom
i don't know too much of the background
of it um and then there's the albino
penis envy which is
i believe it's
a a plus crossed with penis envy i don't
know the exact albino variation don't
quote me on it but i know it's a cross
with penis envy and mindful micronaut
the guy who i showed you the calendar
dude he has this
albino penis envy cross that is [ __ ]
insane where it sends people to dmt
hyperspace if you eat more than like
2.53 grams and you just got to be like
really careful with that specifically he
made makes chocolate bars and [ __ ] out
of them and he's like that's like a
warning hey like don't
this is not the standard like the two
grams of this is not the same as as two
grams of like the [ __ ] you're used to
getting and that's it's [ __ ] insane
like i've seen the fresh mushrooms like
when you open them up like when you cut
them open it's just black in the inside
because like most people know if you're
into eating mushrooms like the bruising
like a lot of people use that as a sign
of like how potent it is like the more
the blue the bruising i don't know if
there's a scientific backing to that but
it's
i think it's true you [ __ ] open up
that ape and it instantly turns [ __ ]
bluish black like you're like [ __ ] oh
like it's scary it makes me like nervous
i want to eat one whole two gram
mushrooms and this is like these little
baseballs they
they
i don't know if i don't think there's
any pictures of it on the calendar
but they look like these little [ __ ]
ufo baseball like [ __ ] all their
crazy looking dude
you might be excited to take money yeah
like oh i got the strains the lemon tag
i put on music for my phone this is what
happens when it's illegal you don't know
about all the differences it sounds so
fun
me i need to do what you do i need at
least one try at least try it once you
want to go you take i thomas i promise
you you take one day and you dedicate it
to like
i don't know what's going whatever you
need to figure out or anything not just
that it's not just about mental health
it's business decision i've came up with
so many
crazy like things and decisions in my
life where i want to head
well i'm and i'm saying you because i'm
not going to encourage people to go take
mushrooms you've already eaten mushrooms
you already know so i can tell you this
you know so
i get it you take one day and
yeah just
if you just really just spend it just by
be by yourself you i don't know rosie
just all inward man you'll really like
come out with a lot of insight in
things that you maybe have been thinking
about and then things that the mushrooms
will come and bring about that you had
no idea about it'll
i want to try the ones you're eating
that's like i can definitely make that
fun
hold on that sounds like some intense
[ __ ] i should say
i've never taken the apes yet i haven't
had the courage to do it yet but i will
soon i've been to like i've tried the
penis and but like the apes
um and if i do try the apes i'll
probably just be like 1.5 for the first
time or maybe no probably a gram
probably ground one point yeah graham
for the first time makes me scared
i'm thinking i keep imagining eating a
mushroom like an apple and i'm thinking
oh my god be so [ __ ] up
um but yeah i have to explain my trip
the full trip to some people like that
sounds like dmt but it was mushrooms
sweaty guys ate mushrooms
people that he's given him to not that i
know but like the homie who [ __ ]
grows them he's told me dude i've given
these to people and they've come back
and told me like yo i went to hype or
like [ __ ] like it was like dmt
i've done i know what that's like so
it's like [ __ ] bro and
if you're just prolonging that
experience because dmt is like quick
yeah but now
ours mushrooms and dmt are really
similar in a way it's hard to explain
the feeling the the feeling it gives
yeah and then when you look at the
chemical structure they're very similar
scary yeah
too much all right my fear is like oh
let's try these mushrooms
like you said these are not the same
what the [ __ ] and i just [ __ ] take
four grams of those and oh
lose my [ __ ]
you just i think that you're like
saying enough to just like be able to
tough it out you would just oh i'll be
yeah you'll be fine but you would
definitely have a train [ __ ] like
come like yeah i would want to go to
sleep just so i don't have to deal with
it
that's what i would try to do right i
don't want to deal with this [ __ ] go
asleep yeah this is like you're falling
asleep on mushrooms
no i don't think so i have once it's
[ __ ] weird
i don't think it allows me to they
weren't hitting me hard and i was just
so tired laying there
fell asleep
started dreaming i started dreaming some
weird [ __ ] woke up and felt all like
what the [ __ ] what off oh mushrooms
that's what happened it's like they it's
like i skipped the really [ __ ] up part
and just got to the body high like oh
yeah you get the string like i'm on a
[ __ ] puppet like i feel like
someone's tugging my clothes and i'm
walking
one of my favorite things is walking
around [ __ ]
gone on mushrooms it just feels like
when you get off a treadmill you're just
walking like there's not really steps
i'm just gliding around this [ __ ]
place
i feel like i can just not move and i
would still
[Music]
if i didn't move my feet i would just
slide around at the airport yes
that's how i feel when i'm on streams
like dude i don't even have to walk do
people ever uh i'm sure it's
you know do people smoke dmt while
tripping balls on mushrooms there's
people there there's a term for that
called candy flipping which i thought
that was acid and mushrooms i think i
could be wrong okay but i think candy
flipping just means taking two different
like
got you i don't think it's specific
i don't know i think but
yeah there's i have never had the balls
to do that you have balls if you do that
you're a [ __ ] like you
yeah i've done dmt and i've broken
through and i've done a video explaining
my whole breakthrough experience and
that is like [ __ ] something else on
your channel yeah i've talked about that
and yeah
[ __ ] insane something else so i could
not imagine
i took it alone
i could not imagine being on like the
peak of a mushroom trip and then taking
a fat dmt hit like what the [ __ ]
[Music]
you're gonna
you're not coming back
oh no no thank you [ __ ] that
um we we did some candy flipping earlier
and we forgot i assumed some bunch of
stuff yeah we were on fan questions man
like an hour ago remember that
we took a fan question about the class
oh
can we go to the next fan question
oh yeah yeah that was really the only
ones i pulled i think everything we've
kind of hit
oh okay okay coach just making share
because i just remember like
whoa
that was a long time ago
mid-episode it's okay it's okay it's
okay um
so we got some mushrooms down
my question
what do you have planned because you
told me
you just told us all i want to live on a
[ __ ] my own land and be able to do
what i want 100
besides that because we what we're
talking about on the in the car right
here about content and whatnot what's
the next step for you like
do you want to continue making videos do
you want to do stuff like that
what what's the next step like do i want
to continue making stuff like what link
videos oh 100 yeah that's what i mean do
you want to keep this direction yeah so
like so i've had a lot of um
like weed videos i will always make just
it's like it's how i
built my following it's
sentimental to me because it's like it's
where i brought myself to where i am
like just building that following so
i'll never stop doing that um
i've had a lot of uh like
what's the word like i've thought about
making a second channel to do like vlog
content without weed
but i'm just
exactly but i'm just not sure like how
we were talking about earlier i'm not
sure if i like want to put that workload
on top of what i'm doing i would have to
find a way to make it work as far as
finding an editor like we were saying
um and then also is that drive because
if i did do vlogs it would be like
camping like i'm gonna get a truck and
like drive across the us but
i was planning to buy a truck and i
still am but i feel like i kind of feel
like the smart move is to get a house
first
for me i don't know
yeah
exactly you always have the [ __ ]
truck come and go but you can always
have the house and it's like i would i
feel like i'd be pissed if i just like
i'm stuck like i have a truck of course
a truck is cool you know truck content
videos and
um
traveling across the u.s living in the
back of my truck [ __ ] cooking meals
and [ __ ] shout out to mav it's like some
youtuber he has no idea who i am but i
found his channel through ice fishing
because i went ice fishing last time and
i had a great time so i went on youtube
and typed in ice fishing to see how like
some how the big dogs are doing it you
know found this dude's channel and he's
like a kid who's like 26 maybe 20 i
don't know somewhere around there and
all his content is is just like
traveling across the us
across the u.s fishing living in the
back of his truck doing like super fun
[ __ ] and i love doing that stuff like
that's what truly makes me happy so i've
gone through like should i make it
second channel and like do that [ __ ] but
if i do it's like maybe after i get my
house like
but um you see what you're saying well
maybe you can pay for help you pay for a
house that's all
that would be an investment because you
buy that truck and then it's like i know
i'm going to make even just
the second channel
exactly the second channel brings a
whole new uh stream of avenue because as
most of you guys know youtube doesn't
pay a dime to
um
cannabis content creators if it's you
know
so yeah zero dollars and if you're
getting paid [ __ ] and bomb yeah if you
are then yeah good for you jesus christ
you must be in pain
um
so that's what that's what the next step
is maybe start the second channel
continue doing weed videos yes possibly
[ __ ] with some more music
but stage [ __ ] making that your career
is not something you really want i don't
want to say no because i don't want to
like disappoint anyone and say no
because like it's always also been a
dream and to like i have a very strong
uh following shout out to all my russian
followers i love you guys um
i would it would be insane to go out to
russia and do like a show out there
because i know i could like in moscow
like the play is like the fault i know
it's there that's where your biggest
bank ram race is
so when i look at the numbers it's like
moscow
saints petersburg
and la those are like the top three and
it sometimes like fluctuates like it
goes back and forth but those are the
top three
so like how cool would it be to go like
i've i want to travel the world and
whatnot like go to russia that would be
so [ __ ] cool you know like yeah but
that's why i was asking you know you
don't want to do a live show but you do
if it's the one that you want to do i
get it yeah you're not just going like
oh i'm going to play the [ __ ] six
she's gonna work the road for [ __ ] 20
years yeah i'm trying to do this [ __ ]
it's not what i wanted to live in the
[ __ ] off the grid like i want to do
other stuff yeah dude you could have a
whole nother
avenue
of fans just based off that other
channel too
because i've seen you you're [ __ ]
making your own fires and [ __ ] i've seen
you do this crazy [ __ ]
[ __ ] full [ __ ] it goes back to the
morning so when i grew up with the
mormons i did lots of campouts and [ __ ]
with them and all those so like i
haven't had i was never an official
scout but a lot of the things they did i
could have technically got a merit badge
for
i'm not like a camping expert by any
means but like i
know how to get a fish and
you do all that stuff yeah exactly so
outdoorsman stuff yeah i'm not like an
expert on any means but i kind of know
my way around luckily i was grown up
around that and i think they're super
good things to take with me
in the future but
it's yeah like if you're asking like do
i want to keep making videos 100 but as
far as like
my future and like
where i kind of want to live and what
makes me happy it's like yes like 100
percent land
and you can still do what you're doing
out there but yeah you can still and
no one's going to bug you because
at the end of the day like my what i
value in life is what makes me happy and
i know a hundred percent what would make
me happy
is just
i don't i can't say if i'm gonna have a
wife kids or anything like that would be
cool but if if that's not the case
that's fine i'll literally happily
happily live by myself with my dogs in a
little house just out kind of in the
middle of nowhere and have a pond maybe
go fishing and like that to some people
that's people are like what the [ __ ]
that sounds like really boring but like
any time i've like living in the city
anytime i've gone to somewhere where
it's off remote and it's like i feel
like i'm reconnecting with something
within that
we're losing and i want to connect back
with that i
[ __ ] feel you my [ __ ] homie oh gee
does the grounding [ __ ] we just walk
around a forest
with no shoes for a [ __ ] hour and
[ __ ] it's good for you yeah you always
tell me come on let's go
bring a gun [ __ ]
up there
oh for sure it's the grass doesn't like
joe rogan see like a bear or something
when he used to live out here i have no
idea i i swear there was like a mountain
lion that's what it was yeah he used to
see all kinds of [ __ ] yeah there was i
used to see all kinds
i think he was when he lived out here he
was out on a jog and he saw him out oh
yeah [ __ ] of course yeah the mountain's
right here [ __ ] that [ __ ] so i don't
want to live up in the burbank hills
there's [ __ ] mountain lions like
odi's and [ __ ] i jogged up on a coyote i
was jogging around my neighborhood i
didn't have my contacts in i thought it
was a [ __ ] dog it was sitting
literally in the little dog park area in
our old neighborhood jogged right up to
it got pretty close looked like the
[ __ ] i am legend wolf i just kind of
backed away dude coyotes are weird they
look like weird dogs like i was trying
to get my [ __ ] food over here and
toluca lake got out i was like is that a
[ __ ] is that a is that a wolf and i got
back in my car i'm like then that [ __ ]
ran the other way yeah but then i was
like almost in between like a wolf and a
dog kind of but like weird it's like a
skinny i don't know it's like you're
was just a couple months ago i'm pulling
into my dad's neighborhood and there was
one just crossing the road and it was
late at night so i stopped like there
was no cars coming i rolled down the
window and me and we're just like
looking at looking at each other that's
what they're trying to get you to roll
down you wouldn't jump your ass there
was one in the middle of the road oh
okay that's the other two oh i already
know how they work yeah yeah i know that
but i'm in my car i'd [ __ ] run that
[ __ ]
over out
you're smart people be like that's
animal cruelty broke coyotes will try
and eat your dog like what do you mean
the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ] they
will try and eat your dog everyone heard
it and your cat unless it's trying to
hurt me exactly then i'm gonna [ __ ]
people's elbow hundred percent a [ __ ]
cougar yes no it didn't do anything i
looked at it i even i was like whistled
i don't know why i did that but then i
just
it's all domesticated it's like looked
at me and then i just drove off i was
like yeah that's what rolls over and
shook yeah
i know this is a dream yeah runs it over
sorry peter damn we got [ __ ] youtube
mad at us trippers and peta good episode
variety of topics i love that every time
i see ashtrays like this i just know
it's a good episode
it's good [ __ ] what are we at i'm gonna
say 210
214. oh
all right nice
pretty good um marty do you have
anything you wanted to ask this was fun
this was a great [ __ ] episode i
learned a lot about mushrooms yeah oh
yeah it's got me fired up to one of them
i know i want to eat one of those ones
off your calendars i'm over here
thinking yeah it's about time
yeah i know that [ __ ] looked like some
[ __ ] hook uh
just eat them
you normally just eat them like just
like boom um no somebody on snapchat a
long time ago gave me a really good idea
you roll out a fruit roll up i've done
that before it really worked because
everybody the rainbow belts too the
airhead rainbow balance is smart as well
but i kind of want to try the lemon
texture it's just a shot
no i love that i don't want to eat a
bunch of candy
i take a spoon and i sit there for 20
minutes
like in a [ __ ] cup and then scrape
the lemons and then that's when i
just breathe and then by the time i have
a like i'd look at the clock all right i
got about like
20 30
minutes to stabilize myself get
confident and by the time the mushrooms
are ready for me i'm ready
you're going to be that old [ __ ] 70
year old man going now this is how
you're supposed to do it yeah you got to
put on it it's going to become so
popular by the time i'm old i feel like
and there's going to be so much done
like like have you seen with how you see
the weed industry oh it's only a matter
of time with the there's legal shrooms
right now have you seen those
in oakland new mexico no the legal
streams that you can ship any 50 states
have you not seen those no what the [ __ ]
so they all said they're lions main
oh so
been
[Music]
extracted
all right mines means legal okay that's
why okay
how do i explain this how do i explain
this i read the package somebody help us
out
my friend eats them they're legal you
can buy them they're mushroom
gummies mushroom chocolate i doubt it
has an active ingredient in it i get it
i understand and they took them and go
bro i'm not tripping balls i definitely
feel like i ate some mushrooms i feel
giggly as [ __ ] and i feel
wobbly as hell really
what yo i'm not hallucinating to see
what that is they're there i mean rosie
ate him and she was having a [ __ ]
laugh attack on the couch for 30 minutes
about nothing
are these really hitting you guys i love
because she's someone sneaking in
[ __ ] magic you never know what the
[ __ ] like that really makes me wonder
like if you're actually like
but they're legal they're legal to ship
all over the country because they're not
psilocybin
okay isn't that [ __ ] insane yeah at
least that's a little uh
mushroom light yeah the hhc version
of mushrooms like it's a lighter version
here here maybe we'll get you to open
your eyes a little bit
you know what i'm saying is in oakland i
think it's what else you say colorado
new mexico new mexico too for troops i'm
not sure that's the two that i'm 100 on
that i'm like pretty sure there's i
don't know if it's the whole state of
new mexico but i know they had a thing
where you can like
and then also in arizona there's my one
one of my friends uh
was telling he was even inviting me that
like to this legal thing where you can
go and take mushrooms and there's like a
shaman and this is in phoenix
that's fun i think it's legal i just
want to be around that mother many
people got to be honest but same
yeah but um yeah there's a legal version
you got to look it up i got it when i
went to champs there was like 15 places
shrooms shroom something something
something true mushrooms all over the
booth [ __ ] legal packages gummies
drinks this that all that [ __ ]
it was pretty wild interesting because
you mentioned lion's mane i know that's
like really good for you yeah yeah but i
saw the ingredients when this is getting
you guys giggly as [ __ ] like that maybe
like a combination thing who knows legal
all 50 states wow
so loopholes loopholes coming very soon
to thedobashop.com
holy [ __ ] the dopest shrooms
you guys know here yeah no [ __ ] yeah if
that's legal and rosie was laughing her
ass off like that
i can at least [ __ ] help some people
out because there's people out there
like i can't get mushrooms we're getting
mushrooms at he's got to like figure out
what exactly is in there like what is it
before we do any of that i have to try
it i have to like it i have to make sure
what's coming on where the farm's coming
yeah you're not just going to [ __ ]
push it out with that yeah yeah i've got
to test it out 100 i'll never sleep like
with this [ __ ] i had to i have to smoke
every single thing first yeah before i
let them do anything
i can't they should've got i'm like i'm
[ __ ] high as [ __ ] right now my lungs
are just like ugh you smell i don't want
to be able to talk long ribs dude yeah
right before we try
yeah i ate those tacos and i felt like i
was like [ __ ] i'm so full i need to get
high like you know that feeling i don't
know about it yeah but when i'm full of
[ __ ] and i smoke weed i feel even worse
because i'm like i'm the opposite cough
and throw up i'm the opposite i love
when i'm like really high like i feel
like it balances me out
love a [ __ ] nice session after a meal
so that's why i kind of like came sat
here sorry and like [ __ ]
went ham with like took multiple bong
grips just to kind of like
level back yeah level back out because i
felt so full because i got they [ __ ]
up the order and then we got extra tacos
so i was like [ __ ] dude postmates is
[ __ ] up today yeah
my order your order just like two
separate places two separate drivers
still [ __ ] it all up
it's all good uh marty like i said
earlier you said this was fun then we
started talking about mushrooms anything
else you want to add a [ __ ] eye yeah
i'm just glad this was so highly
requested aside from like goblin aircon
this is this is like what people ask for
the
weed
video creators on this channel are
always going to do awesome because
dude this is what we do this is what i
do like this is our
there's no where else we're going to go
that we can
go on a podcast and talk about the weed
[ __ ] like this
almost no who else like i don't see a
lot of other podcasts even talking about
we like this and it's not like every
episode's about we but when it's when
it's you when it's eric or got like
bro we gotta smoke we definitely smoke
weed for [ __ ] living let's talk about
that we're actually going to talk about
that on a platform
and i'd like that
yours we barely touched on me videos
today you know that yeah barely touched
on weed videos because you're doing so
much
so much more there's so much other [ __ ]
you could be branching off and doing
what you are doing yeah and you need an
editor so as of right now you need an
editor to help you
expedite this process because you don't
like editing it takes too long it's it's
a full-time job that's one of the things
where i'll just like be honest with you
guys you're like you don't upload all
the time it's like i am great at i feel
like getting footage
but a lot of times
it's just hard to
it takes so long to edit the videos to
how exactly i want to do it so if i had
an editor what i'm saying so i had an
editor where i could just like
make it a flow oh i would so many more
videos would be coming out so
hopefully i can make that happen i know
obviously i set my mind to it i can do
it so yeah you got it yeah i got it for
french anybody watching just like cole
cole's watching now he's editing all our
[ __ ] so if there's anybody out there
that watches
raw og and like this is my [ __ ]
chance right here
that's what you need exactly and
like we said it's perfect because if you
already watch the channel you already
have an idea because i obviously who
wants to come onto a channel and be like
oh he got an editor and it's like
completely different you don't want that
to happen you want it to be a smooth
transition where
it's still the same style but maybe in a
way a little better yeah yeah or just
take the time off you exactly
spend more time to focus on
um
coming up with cooler videos filming
working on the high spirit you know so
many other things so many other avenues
man exactly you can't [ __ ] cancel or
you can't shadow bandages close it yeah
it takes
months or not months sorry i wasn't i
meant to say hours
it takes hours to edit like a single
video for me at least like multiple
hours
a lot
what was it i don't do it all in one day
at least recently i'll like spend this
many hours a day and then come back
because like i'll burn myself out of
because i've done that before and then
after i'm done editing i'm like
never again i don't even want to do it
again and i don't want to do that to
myself so
yeah i'm not trying to complain if
anyone's like oh how you're complaining
like i love it i love what i do but it
just can make it not fun it can make it
not fun 100 you're not a computer editor
no i don't know why i got into it no
that's that's really what it comes down
to man like i'm decent i kind of like
people really give me problems like oh
you're real and it's like thank you so
much like i think i'm decent but it's
only because
you do something for so long you're
gonna get decent you're going to get
decent at it you know i don't consider
myself really good at any but i've been
doing it for so long on vegas pro that's
what i use windows
vegas pro is a program what i've never
heard of that before sony vegas pro
that's some og throwback [ __ ] really i
i've been seeing i've been using that
since i was a kid and i haven't switched
i know a lot of like there's the what's
the
mac programs
imovie final cut when i took a
video production class in high school i
had to use final cut and i hated it
because i was just like i don't like mac
i'm just so used to windows interface i
just haven't made that transition i
don't know if i ever will
no i feel you dude i just i i just used
premier
rush and it sucked
no i don't [ __ ] i don't even i haven't
even heard of that it's like light
the light version of premiere and then
for music fl studio i don't know if
you've heard of
fl studio is another
it's a program but for music it's the oh
it's the og beat maker fruity loops yeah
fruity loops yeah that's what it stands
for yep really
oh yeah that's the first [ __ ] people
were oh yeah it's on just had the little
you just have i mean the [ __ ] was like
sick you just have the little sounds
they just bleep bleep i used to watch
people make beats and fruity loops that
[ __ ] yeah still the [ __ ] yeah
so
editing you need an editor yes to
expedite and or to delegate
you know because i love doing the vlog
so where it's like sometimes when you're
doing something but sometimes you need
someone to actually holding a camera and
following you that's really really nice
to have to set it every time and
honestly like luke like for like he's
not a professional videographer at any
time but a lot of times like he does
help me out with that so that's cool but
like i would be cool to have like an
actual like dedicated like videographer
yes you plan your [ __ ] out
hey this day we film
come every time yeah here
you got it down you just got to get it
a little more in
unison with everything yes yeah but you
almost know that i just i found it two
weeks ago so
don't you don't feel like you're lagging
yeah you you have time and things like
this take time
you'll find all these things take time
you'll find it eventually so
real quick where can everybody find you
at
social media wise
social media raw brandon on instagram
that's i mean
i don't want to jinx anything because
you know how it is
robran i've been i've been on there for
a while been on there for a while with
that one rob brandon raw og 420 for
youtube
raw og 420 on youtube og 420 on youtube
i need to get more active on my snapchat
but i have a live like over a hundred
thousand people on snapchat that i
really need to like actually use
yeah exactly i was really active on it
for a while and i know there's a lot of
people watching this and they're like i
know
why aren't you [ __ ] posting
snapchat is raw og 420 as well just like
youtube yeah so youtube and snap raw
g420 and then instagram is raw brandon
okay what about your music where can
people find that
um so soundcloud spotify apple music
evil main can you spell it
just the last part evil evil what's the
last m-a-n-e
man main with an e yes just in case
people like evil m-a-i-n never evil man
with an e evil man with an e evil
perfect for everybody out there all the
illiterate ass fools out the client's
name but thank you yeah just in case so
everybody can go listen to that [ __ ] i
suggest you go just go peep it
i was [ __ ] pleasantly surprised and
one thing i want to say is
i came up with this name before i even
decided i want to do music
in what
early years like it's like been almost
like 10 years now it seems like
eight years
there's so many people have come i know
may like there's gucci mane ghost man
like i'm not saying that i made anything
new at all by any means yeah but within
the span of like me there is so
many main main main main in this like
genre and a lot of people like
i'm i'm just
happy that i
you know when you made that [ __ ] you go
oh i like these artists i'm just going
to use it evil snatch it
no i get it i get it you just made it to
make him like oh this is pretty cool it
was beautiful i even wanted to make
music and then it just got boom and then
like i've even asked someone like do you
have have you ever thought about
changing your name and i'm like no i'm
holding it down because this is what i
had before everyone [ __ ] like and i'm
not saying i'm the first but like before
it got like [ __ ] insane and everyone
started using this everyone started
doing it i'll say this if i didn't if
that wasn't my name there would already
be another artist named evil main
hundred percent hundred percent there'd
be another artist named that making some
some of the same 100 probably shittier
though
no dude um you have to
you have to say that [ __ ] like i'm not
riding coattails [ __ ] i already
have this name also i like those artists
exactly like both those artists i'm not
saying i was aware of them when they
made the [ __ ] yeah so there's some cool
names out there but i'm just stuck with
it i just tried to say that yeah cause
someone because i made that [ __ ] like a
couple years ago then i saw the rappers
making the songs about pushing me i go
oh
i don't give a [ __ ]
but don't be thinking i may i'm riding
coattails because i make the shirt yeah
it's almost a joke now a meme like of
the main within the underground like
funk community when it's like a little
it's like
oh when's another main gonna come out or
exactly like you said lil
when's another lil gonna come out
it's almost cliche yes it becomes cringe
at a certain point but hey i
i
not me
not me not me
hermione you
yo
they almost said star wars some harry
potter [ __ ] that was some good accent
favorite lines i love harry potter's my
favorite series is it yeah i've never
seen them all i've only watched like two
i think i saw one where a bunch of them
died and then i saw the first one
which one was that i don't know a bunch
of these kids died at school and [ __ ]
that was crazy
trying to think [ __ ] harry potter some
[ __ ] some alien [ __ ]
voldemort awesome oh it was probably the
fourth it was probably the fourth the
full from
when
powder
killed cedric who was now batman
so the kid who got murdered in the
fourth harry potter by voldemort when
voldemort first came back i know you're
not too familiar he's a kid from
twilight and now batman yeah he's like
and that's how i first knew him like
when he first went on to twilight i
already knew him no that's cedric that's
not a [ __ ] harry potter no that's
cedric no i never [ __ ] harry potter i
just uh
when i watched them they were sick yeah
they were [ __ ] cool
great storyline i also read the books
when i was little by the fourth grade i
got up to the fifth book and then
stopped reading it because the fifth
book was so boring for me i read number
one because my grandma bought it from me
because i liked it and i didn't want to
hurt her feelings did you read it
yeah so she bought me the next one
saying i knew you liked the first one so
i bought you the next my grandma thank
you so much i'll read it christmas oh my
god the third one went oh grandma i'm so
sorry the hardbacks the hardbacks yeah
these are expensive they're like rare
now and she was buying them back then
too i mean i just gave to somebody
i'm not sure but i know yeah dude my
books were so torn up i don't even like
yeah i don't think my books like my
uncle got them for me and my brother
oh how many symbols you got just one
brother older younger he's older he's
older by two years oh okay so yeah
you're close yeah he's got you his
tattoos and [ __ ] yeah okay you live out
there too yeah he lives in vegas oh wait
yeah you said he moved out with you and
then you got your own spot yeah got you
sorry i'm over here over here like
bringing it back up but i know we were
like closing it up yeah yeah so how many
brothers you got yeah my bad um
so
yeah i think i think that was everything
i wanted to ask let's go learned a lot
today thank you for the mushroom [ __ ]
tech [ __ ] yeah thank you i really want
to
[Music]
we'll talk about more about it but i
really want to take a day for myself
yeah
okay i always have to worry about the
damn phone man i have to do emails and
dudes i was telling yola in the car man
i see what you're doing i don't know how
like you are doing so many things at
once non-stop everyday
props because it takes a lot of mental
willpower to like not only not burn out
keep going you also have a like so many
people that are relying on you now you
have a team like there's so much it's
just it's not just you it's based
it's more now you have a warehouse you
have [ __ ] marty now you have people
doing your orders like it's it's big
yeah it's a lot so seeing how you've
built it to that you stay consistent
props to you man you're [ __ ] killing
it dude yes thank you thank you and
you're an inspiration to me that's most
people even i've said this
push trees inspired high spirit and
i remember talking about it yeah because
good though man yeah seeing how
like youtube is just [ __ ]
not making it really hard for us to make
it work so building the brand and having
something to give back to the audience
and like make something dope and also
make money doing it you know that's the
whole point if you could make some
people go get the [ __ ] out of you look
at what i got and you made money doing
it [ __ ]
so doing that is like awesome because
who knows if i would have [ __ ]
started it without that or without
youtube not
just giving us the [ __ ] hammer yeah
all of us well that's the only thing if
you're going to last you evolve and do
something else yeah that's what you're
doing there's been so many times
even have a video why i haven't been
uploading and even in that video i was
talking about how if i like should i
i almost like i don't know if i was
going to be able to keep doing this you
know because i wasn't getting anything
out of it it's just like i'm uploading
videos like what can i do and then it's
like i need to make something work i
need to make it happen
he has to monetize in some way because
if not just like i cannot survive doing
this full-time yeah doesn't work that's
where seeing you i was like he's making
it work he's doing all these things and
you even commented on that video i don't
know if you remember it was a while back
yeah
it was just like i've been following you
for a while man like
i was like sick i hope yeah helped me
with that so thank god dude i'm glad you
said you watched the video with the
llc's and [ __ ] so i did i watched the
dopaziola video or it may have been on
the adventures yolo where you talked
about starting a clothing brand and
using legalzoom that's what i did i
literally followed that so it's funny
like another content creator that now
i'm saying i watched that video and i
did exactly that so good yeah everybody
out there trying to start some clothing
[ __ ] or any business go watch that video
yeah you're going to go through trials
and errors like there's still things
that i'm going to go through i'm still
in the beginning stages but you just got
to keep at it whatever you're doing
whether it's
anything like it's not just business
starting your own business but
you just got to find a way to make it
happen like you said i just want to do
music just to do music because i love it
now i'm monetized somehow made weave
videos because i love weed now i'm
[ __ ] monetized somehow
you just love it you keep trying keep
going [ __ ] yeah what we're doing
well we're [ __ ] like literally what
the [ __ ] we're doing yeah you're you're
in the same footsteps man we're doing
the same thing you're just
you're getting it together you're it's
it's where it's supposed to be you're
expediting the process right now and
like i said dude you're 23. yeah you're
doing it very sometimes like you like
give myself slack because sometimes i'm
hard on myself
you know yeah but it's also good in a
way yeah
you're accountable for you now yeah
because it's like i'm only 20 sometimes
like bro you're just 23 you're not
supposed to have everything figured out
and all done but then
it's like i don't know you're supposed
to feel like rush like you're rushing
towards it though that's good to feel
okay that's a good thing it's like a
fire lit under you because if not you
might take five days off there's nothing
there's no plan b like there's no like
i'm gonna fail at this
like that's not like
there's no i'm not working for someone
else i'm not living that life i'm not
doing it yeah i cannot do it i'm not
being told what to do i'm not and and if
you do that and you're i'm not hating on
anyone who does it like i'm trying to
think i'm better just your personality
it's my personal and some people are
super happy what they do and that's
perfectly but me personally like i were
talking about me in kindergarten ever
since i was a [ __ ] kid before i can
even like conceptualize what a job is i
already didn't like people telling me
what to do so just like yeah no you're
on your own [ __ ] you want to live in the
forest do with your
dogs don't like the government telling
me what to do i don't like anyone like
get away from me you guys are annoying
not not when i say you guys are annoying
i'm talking about the government in the
general in the general spirit of the
government oh no we just got
demonetized you guys are annoying that's
what i meant not not like people like i
love a lot of people yeah but no people
can be [ __ ] dicks too for sure and
also that's why you want to move away
yeah get away from some [ __ ]
yeah i would be right the more you can
the more you can rely on yourself the
better the less the less you got to rely
on the corporations and governments and
[ __ ] the more you can sustain yourself
it's truly better and i know not that's
not an option for everyone but me that's
really what i want to strive for you
know
i'm not gonna be able to just like
go live in this small house and start
growing up my food and busting out a
farm but like i want to start small
maybe start growing my own vegetables
[ __ ] like that maybe go down the road to
a local produce where there's actually
like
good [ __ ] being grown where it's not you
know i'm sure you know a lot of the [ __ ]
in the grocery stores it's not really
good for us yeah we're
i get it we're going to pathalights all
these different things that's
[ __ ] with our hormones like there's
so many things like a lot like that it's
just bad i'm not an expert on it by any
means but yeah
so you know what you want yeah so
hopefully one day you're doing videos
from your [ __ ] forest cabin that
would be sick that's how i i would feel
like i know i
accomplished i made it and i yeah as
long as you're like you said that's not
what makes me happy if whatever you're
doing makes you happy then you're
winning yeah no seriously and i really i
really
realized that
do what makes you happy [ __ ] what anyone
else says seriously i know you everyone
has heard that and has heard that in
their life i know that everyone for real
is hard exactly when you do it
because most people don't have their
have their [ __ ] figured out as much as
you think most people who are judging
you don't got it like you think they got
it like
yeah most people have their own issues
they have their own demons they're
battling whatever so
don't take people's opinions into her
because most people
are hiding a lot of [ __ ] themselves or
whatever the case may be
said it perfectly yeah that's what i
said earlier mike oh that phil said that
oh he's hurting
making being mean to me oh something's
wrong yeah let's leave him alone
something's bad his life sucks let's not
make it worse yeah so basically do what
you want hopefully it turns into a
paycheck
do what you love
good episode thank you i learned a lot
and mushrooms we'll talk more after but
all right are you ready for these
[ __ ] mushroom adventures we're gonna
go on one day yeah i think i am me too
yeah i am too after those we gotta flash
the calendar up on the screen or some
[ __ ] yeah
yeah mushrooms are great maybe not a
group of people
everybody just imagine
the calendar oh go to highspirit.com
and check out that calendar that's the
way you can check it out all right
because if we flash it up here you i've
ate in a lot of those different
mushrooms you see on those calendars
that's all you've probably eaten those
actual ones too not not the actual ones
you see in the picture but like the
actual genetic if that makes sense like
that yeah it's it's grown by my boy
mindful micah not he also has an
instagram he's also known as wonka
um
yeah
he's killing it he does a [ __ ] great
job and i love him
[ __ ] yeah yeah
well dude first interview ever great
[ __ ] job
good job let's go this was great oh yeah
i know you said i'm a little nervous i
i'll say this before it ends i was
really nervous the first but i kind of
felt myself just like all right i'm
chill
i i felt nervous in the beginning and i
you're fine i felt myself stumble over
myself a couple times but i felt as
though as it went on i think i'm good
you're fine nothing yeah i hope i always
came across okay you're a hundred
percent i [ __ ] love this episode okay
sweet i love this one i love that you
enjoyed it good stuff yeah everything we
talked about i wanted to know more and i
know you know a lot about [ __ ]
psychedelics i really wanted to talk to
you so thank you now i'm starting to
think like
i'm just getting [ __ ] up you're over
here using this medicine and [ __ ]
breathing and like maybe i should take
it i've had fun times with them too but
most recently yes it's it's such a good
it's
i don't it's like i feel like we're
meant to 100 they can like mess with
your body
it's a reset it's a good it's a good
like reset button you know when you need
it a hundred percent
well when i was putting it up one day
for so long for like the past few months
man i was just like
and i finally did it two days ago like
the podcast is coming up like you just
like this all kind of happened yola
messaged me
and i was mentally not i had to trip
i don't i mean this is the way you said
it mitt i had to trip it's the [ __ ] you
had to clear it out i had to i thought
like and my new
yeah it was just it's been it's been a
little tough that's all yeah and you had
to yeah it'd actually
clear it's like i said it's a reset
button that you're gonna come here and
start talking about a bunch of [ __ ]
you're gonna be feeling all this
[ __ ] like
while i'm trying to tell this story and
[ __ ] i'm feeling like [ __ ] over this
[ __ ]
100 yeah the mushrooms are [ __ ]
strong dude like they
mushrooms are [ __ ] intense
it's been a while since i really really
went hard
but like i said off camera we'll talk
more about it i want to um
i want to try the ones that you're
scared
of apes but like a little it's crazy
they're called the apes like albino
penis envy like
oh that's what you were saying yeah i
just want a
little taste scrape there it is extreme
visuals on those apparently so that's
probably what you want those are known
for having the the strongest
visuals well could you imagine turning
the lights off in the warehouse and
having a nerf gun and all the bullets
are glow in the dark
farm billy all the people who go to
those electric
daisy edc like all right yeah but
they're around 500 people i don't get to
do that [ __ ] yeah like yo i see you're
demon inside you i see the demon inside
you i don't have to leave
people are so fried i feel like they're
so hype they're not even looking at it
like that because also people are like
mdma and [ __ ] oh yeah yeah yeah
i get it i get it but it's never been
like my i like that drug but i rather do
much i've never done it i loved it yeah
it was [ __ ] funny
don't do it i'm not saying
weed that's it
keep it that way i've never done
anything else yeah keep it right there
yeah you don't need to go anywhere yeah
and i'm totally content with that like
yeah the only other drug that i would
really consider doing there's like two
and they're both psychedelics and that's
ayahuasca
and i don't know if i'm ready for that
yet because that's like a commitment you
know that's like a [ __ ] it's a pretty
tough one
um
in a good way tough one in a good way
and then lsd i've never done acid either
and i've just find it it's it's
i got to get a test kit
yeah because i've seen 25i all these
m-bombs and all these different things
that will make you trip but it's not the
same and it's not as safe like real lsd
as far as i'm concerned you cannot
overdose and die on so
that just gives me a better save my i
know i know i'm taking the real thing so
if i did it it's like you have to let go
like you said to be 100 and that would
help me let go if you knew it was the
real thing too exactly you can't let go
like was that hard yeah
exactly
[ __ ] no don't let don't let no one tell
you if you're listening to this and
you're i'm not telling you to do drugs
but you know you're going to do it and
you've made your mind get it tested
because you buy it no one call you a
[ __ ] or a [ __ ] for it because that's
your body and that's you know how you
don't get another one yes they're online
for safety reasons you can buy drug
testing kits and make sure it's real for
so many things especially with fentanyl
now that's killing everyone
yeah god this is so [ __ ] terrible go
get a tester kit to do your drugs so you
don't die ah
yeah it's so fun
[ __ ] yeah we're going to talk about drug
tests and mushrooms
problems
you're fine it's just you know it's a
mush i mean as long as you don't eat
some [ __ ] that you know it's a magic
mushroom you know no i get it yeah um
[ __ ] dude we keep ranting i know i know
and i keep thinking
did we talk we don't he said we and you
said all this
yeah we got it all i'll just keep trying
to make checklists in my head
you said where to find you right okay so
before we leave
dot highspirit.com that's that's that's
actually support everything that he's
doing because youtube food mats toker
posters beanies his movements are baller
as [ __ ] i have two of them out there
they're badass coach just go look if you
like
style stuff
that's the place you should be checking
out stoner
you should look it up i like the [ __ ]
other mushroom one you had that [ __ ] was
insane the one you wore last time
i can't it was like a light like colored
shirt it was just go on the website high
spirit it was the life is the ritual
that was the ayahuasca ceremony that's
just badass yeah that's his ayahuasca
ceremony encapsulated on a t-shirt of a
dude sitting at a bonfire with a shaman
and all this crazy [ __ ] happening around
it it's just hard yeah
um
okay let's do this rauji brandon
evil main
for anyone out there going what the [ __ ]
whatever kids in russia are watching
going no way
no way
that's what it's for because we have a
lot of most people now
no i'm saying like there's the russian
cancer is kind of like a joke okay yeah
there's that nikita is gonna walk in
what my videographer's from russia just
he's straight from russia yeah so he's
walking like i know you
that's gonna be fun yeah he shows me
crazy ass russian rap and that's just
hard as [ __ ] yeah they're so sick i
don't understand it but it sounds sick
russian is a really interesting language
when you i've been learning it lately
for me why like he's telling me a little
thing well that's how you say that all
right i'll remember that
i hear someone call me that i don't know
if i can get mad all right i know
um
but yeah so all the russian fans out
there
thank you for watching appreciate you
maybe one day that's the goal keep doing
content keep making your clothes keep
doing your things try to live life
make more
videos
there it is
perfect yeah you know where you're
headed you know the direction you want
to be
better than i was it's just all about
executing
trying setting a plan and doing it me
and marty preach this [ __ ] all the
[ __ ] time and you're seeing a living
example and he might be your age too all
right me and marty are a little older
than most of our crowd
here's somebody your age doing exactly
what they want to do
there's an example there's a lot of
other people my age eric good friend of
mine as well oh first yeah eric's
crushing it bro
we're like pretty much i think these are
all twenty maybe like a few months all
you guys are 23. okay goblin you and
eric yeah i've never met going but he
seems really cool but like eric i've
eric has stayed at my house i've hung
out with him multiple times so it's like
yeah he's and i sometimes wait bounce
things goblin's here it's thursday he
just flew in really you should have fun
i'm gonna hit him up he just got here
today wow sorry i [ __ ] he says
sunday i was i pulled into one of his
live streams one time sorry i know we're
ending it but he was doing a prison
simulator and i was like in my kitchen
folding t-shirts for and i was [ __ ]
dying he was just getting
yeah funny guy so i'm gonna hit him up
right now i know he's here but sweet
let's uh all right guys sorry i know
we're trying to end this my bad my bad
this has been the raw g episode thank
you guys so much for watching raw og 420
on youtube raw g420 on snapchat rob
brandon on instagram hi spirit dot co
how the [ __ ] did i remember all that i'm
killing it today
all right thank you guys so much for
watching appreciate you for being here
thank you so much for having me so much
thank you so much for everything from
marty god bless thank you
signing off so awesome this has been the
dope as usual podcast we're here to talk
about life problems drugs
accomplishments a whole lot of mushrooms
and everything in between have a dope
ass day
good [ __ ] oh yeah yeah
all right
that was a good one man i hope i didn't
rent too much dude that's us
we rented less now than ever
real quick check this out
look at
hives hives everywhere
from the keep on my joint
telling you pollen [ __ ] me up
you're allergic for [ __ ] dude i try
not to say anything during it my whole
arm is popped open for a second i had so
many on me i was trying did you see me
doing this for a minute it was i didn't
know so bad you were doing such a good
job because i never noticed i was trying
to not get anybody to notice because
people watch so heavily
[Music]